good morning and good afternoon good
evening everyone welcome back to
GameSpot's best of 2017 countdown today
it is finally time December 20th to do
our mega stream counting down from our
third game to our second to our overall
game of the year as voted and argued on
by the GameSpot staff we very much might
as well get right into it so I'm sure
all of you think you know what this game
is so here's a montage for our number
three game of 2017
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there you have it super mario odyssey
from nintendo is our number three game
of 2017 I'm Mike my Hardy here to chat
about it wit Peter Brown hello again
Randolph ramsey hello everybody and
Justin hey Wald hey hey
you both like this game lot so I figured
you'd bring bring bring you on you
didn't bring me on but you like this
game a lot we we all argued over this
and the number two game because it was
kind of we knew what the top three were
but we had to deliberate on what to
decide to give it to you you kind of
almost spoil the game right that's why
that's why I covered up my sweater
before the stream but here it is now
this is completely coincidental
by the way my wife bought me this she
didn't decide a number three mm blame
your wife but I the T Rexes are in Mario
as well Jeff and I just like dinosaurs I
I was not intentionally buff Santa's not
in it so I can't be blamed for it but
Santa's in Star Wars but anyway Super
Mario Odyssey obviously the next in the
long-running series of one of the most
iconic characters and video games
specifically one of the 3d platformers
what does this game do Justin that kind
of pushed the 3d Mario or the 3d
platformers like evolved it so to speak
I this was a really hard decision to
make especially in a year like 2017 and
you would think like a traditional
platformer it's not gonna live up and
like I thought is well that like Mario's
gonna be in the top ten but getting as
high as it did for number three the
thing that I think really catapulted is
both the new mechanics that introduced
like those are it's really fun to to
take control of other characters to use
the hat and kind of a really not
necessarily innovative but a really
different way for a Mario game but also
that then it just encapsulates fun like
it is it is joy in a in a disc
encapsulate it's fun and it puts you on
a girl you yeah but yeah puns are
already rolling we're watching b-roll of
a new dunk city right here Randy but all
the different kingdoms you go to are
kind of this is the first time you see
real people or whatever that you would
assume are real beauty ins and there's a
lot of weird stuff going on in this game
but how does mechanics kind of coalesce
to actually make the gameplay and the
world design feel like you know like
you're collecting power moons and
usually it's like stars or shines or
what have you but you collecting power
moves in this and you were talking
earlier before women live about how it's
more of a steady stream of them rather
than like one that takes a while to get
and then you go to the next one it's
kind of the stream of like dopamine
releases yeah yeah I think in terms of
like game design they've made a lot of
sort of moves to make it more accessible
to on the go play which the switch is
excellent at and yeah as you said you
know moons and this is like what eight
hundred more than eight hundred moons in
the game yeah so you're only ever like
one or two minutes away from actually
finding something and then the world is
designed you know all the different sort
of like kingdoms are designed in such a
way that you know like anywhere that you
look if you go in that direction you'll
probably find something that is
interesting or a moon that you can
achieve I played this game I think the
bulk of this game I play while I was on
the bus you know to and from work and it
always felt like I was actually
achieving something that I'd made a lot
of progress every time I actually touch
this game it was like a mobile like
experience exactly yeah yeah yeah
pee-yew reviewed this gave it one of the
three ten out of ten Z GameSpot which
means it's essential mm-hmm
what was it about the what makes this
game essential you were talking about
how like the difficulty because the game
much of the platforming isn't difficult
in itself until you get to later stages
you were saying it's difficult in a
different way kind of the way it forces
you to encourage you to look at the
world yeah as Randy was saying you know
let you know pick a direction go there
you'll find something but you you slowly
learned that there are you know certain
rules at play and manipulating the
camera in such a way can can help you
look at the world differently and it's
and it's a lot about deciding like what
your surroundings are and what you're
capable of achieving you know with
Mario's skills and sometimes you know
obviously using Cappy to look beyond
Mario skills and see how the enemies in
the environment help it's not difficult
in that it's challenging it's difficult
in that it challenges you if that makes
sense yeah Justin like we're kind of
we're looking at a toast arena town and
the desert Kingdom or I mean this is the
desert Kingdom toast arena towns off to
the left somewhere but one thing this
game does also it like gives you these
sand boxes rather than these discrete
levels obviously in older Mario's often
times there were open-world aspects or
at least small sandbox open
aspects but this very much encouraged
you to just go explore and that kind of
ties in to the fact that you can find
power moons left and right it anywhere
you want how did you feel that the
sandbox design of the worlds contributed
to the overall experience yeah like like
Randy said it's just it's a lot of fun
it just keeps pulling you along like I
think other Mario games it felt like you
would go into a level and you have a
distinct star that you're going for and
maybe there's some other side things
that you'd go along but here it's like
it's a sense of discovery everything
that you find you're like yeah as you're
going along around here's what I think
I'm gonna do and then you get pulled ons
you said well I see something else I
mean let me try to go do that really
quickly and like it just adds to that
I'm gonna keep playing like I'm just one
more like that I guess a Pringles type
feel like like I can't stop I want to
keep keep grabbing more moons
yeah the also the variety of activity
that you're doing I mean like the
variety is in itself as sometimes you
just a buzzword just described the game
as being fun but this one like I mean
you can you throw your cap at like a
pterodactyl to start gliding around but
then in like five minutes later you're
doing this infuriating minigame where
the guy shows you the steps you're
supposed to take the pattern and then
they disappear for also you have to kind
of it was it was really I thought it was
fun but I sucked at it the circle one in
the desert it took me like six tries and
I literally had to start walking then
just keep the analog stick at that
certain angle but did you find that the
variety of quests or missions or just
power moon challenges were kind of
enough to keep you going from one of the
next Randi I did yeah and I think one of
the sort of the the best things about
this too is you can play this game in a
variety of different ways and I think
accessibility is one of the key things
in this thing right but I think this
game in some quarters has been
criticized for being a little bit too
safe with the Mario formula right like
it didn't actually push you know what
Mario is capable of in the same way that
other games you know push their genres
well but I think you know in the ways
that it did push they're really smart
ways you know just having you know no
lives for example in this one is like a
critical change to to how Mario does
things you know Cappy and you know the
ability to to have it was like a few
dozen different forms you know
throughout the game being able to buy
moons you know I think it is such an
interesting way to try and you know
make you keep up with other people whose
skill levels may be higher than yours if
you want to see more of the endgame or
or delay the stages you don't
necessarily have to go and get all the
moons and you know in each of the world
you can just buy your way through it it
does like so many new interesting things
that makes it I think you know the most
accessible Mario's ever been it's really
interesting as well that it doesn't
unlock new abilities like you go to all
these new worlds you have the same skill
set from the very beginning of the game
the things you're buying are completely
cosmetic but you still you're kind of
driven along like no I want to unlock
this new silly costume or put together a
new combination but no matter what from
the beginning of the game to the end of
the game you have the same skill set
yeah then also the economy kind of
actually it does put you through the
game but like also in terms of the world
design I feel like well without spoiling
anything P like there the story does do
different things here that's not usually
the main focus of a 3d Mario game it's
kind of one of the most rote narratives
and games I would say this does do
different things with it however minor
or they might be are they even minor is
that right well it doesn't make a big
deal about it yeah but it but it
certainly plays with your expectations a
little bit and that's you know that's
when the story is complete but then like
the game opens up to be even broader so
the story again is really not the focus
but it does just sort of remind you that
hey things are a little bit different
now and the way that they do sort of
tinker with your expectations of the
narrative pays off even though it's not
like a a major change
I mean well depending how you look at it
yeah again we don't want spoil it we're
gonna be streaming in a few minutes of
the game itself and we might spoil it
then but in general Justin what was the
what's the number one thing that stuck
with you about Mario ever since it's
what October 27th release you know you
play a lot of Mario games especially
like 3d Mario games what was it that
made this something you want to argue
for right in 2017 there's been there's
so many amazing games like AI I think
this is like one of the hardest game
Lear discussions we've had in in almost
10 years but Mario stood out just
because it it really does capture the
essence of fun like it is just fun in in
the perfect way it's like Nintendo nails
that with their video
games and I lower you I think can
sometimes be a little formulaic
but this one and just felt like the
right game at the right time to just sit
back and enjoy the ride it was an
action-adventure fun movie and maybe it
won't be something that resonates for
you know twenty years down the line but
I think no matter what like capturing
that essence of fun is such such a
Nintendo thing and something that was
just so needed in 2017 for me I always
bring like the angle I bring into our
gang sport Game of the Year discussions
is always the old man
dad vote yeah and for me like you
mentioned it may not you know have that
resonance in twenty years I actually
think it might because you know like I
played this with my with my
eight-year-old son and he he essentially
played this entire game solo I tried to
help him you know as much as I could but
he managed to like actually get to the
end defeat the final boss and now he's
going through all the extra challenges
like all on his own and it was only
until halfway through that he realized
he could actually turn assist mode on so
you know in terms of you know impact on
you know someone who's younger like you
know I think this is this generation
Super Mario 64 right like this is the
game that you know my son will remember
in 20 years time as the game that got
him into Mario sure and it's only like a
much stronger argument for the Nintendo
switch as if it needed anymore this year
it's almost like another case for intend
Oh making a huge comeback in 2017 it's
crazy where the switch is that right now
I think we all saw Zelda and Mario
coming and we knew that there were other
games arriving but it's just it's crazy
to look back now or at least just look
at my switch man you'd be like wow like
there are more games I want to play this
second on my switch than on any other
platform you told me that a Nintendo
platform would be my preferred console
of 2017 I probably would not believe you
a year ago believe it yeah now it makes
sense
anyway Super Mario Odyssey is GameSpot's
number three game of 2017 if you're
watching this on youtube or GameSpot
after we talked about it live go catch
up on the rest of our game of the year
we went near automata what remains be to
finch hell BladeCenter was sacrificed
Wolfenstein to the new order horizon
zero dawn divinity original sin - and
resen evil 7 we have not announced the
next two yet we will do that shortly if
you're watching this live
but go catch up on that and we are going
to stream Super Mario Odyssey right now
for a little bit before we announce our
number two games so stick around unless
you don't want something spoiled because
what we're gonna play a late game stage
or no okay maybe like we will try not to
spoil a at this point because we're
showing something that they've been
showing it
III for like years now all right Justin
let's jump right in
yeah so we're in new dog city here I'm
not even gonna go into the menu that
shows off the stages because they if you
haven't beaten it yet that could be a
little bit spoiler mmm but this week
this had one of my favorite levels the
this is like one of the more code what
were you saying Randy do we consider
costumes spoilery showing off some of
the major spoilers I'd say but castings
are fine yeah
Diddy Kong costume okay there you go do
the Diddy Kong costume if you can get it
do you have it in this who's your safety
yeah
you have most of them right at Muslim I
think I'm missing like the skeleton
which takes like 9 thousand 999 coins I
think maybe like one other yeah it's
let's play I was telling you guys we you
know one of the best things about this
was you know I've played this for
countless hours and I'm still
discovering new things I you know my son
showed me another way to give into the
Odyssey the other day that I never
actually saw before how there's a
porthole on the top of it ah yeah yeah
you know already you didn't know you
could go around the pipe of it I didn't
know you could go around the pipe know
around the pipe yeah yeah like at the
back there's there's a pipe that you can
go in you had the Hat correct the first
time but yeah someone with the long bill
area yeah it was just really cute and
his feet like slap on the ground when he
runs I'm like pub gee people take their
shoes off so they don't make as much
noise but it makes like a slapping noise
tight say if you can go up here yeah
yeah I only discovered this two days ago
and he was trying to tell me and I went
you can't tell me anything that I don't
know about this game oh you can go down
yeah yeah I didn't I didn't actually
know about that flip-top
yeah thought give it a vote you have got
a lot of ways to get out of this uh
whoops you don't hate traffic
sleeping a new dog said he has like one
of the quests you might say that a lot
of people are talking about mmm
everyone's talking brain everyone's
talking about it
mmm it's not Trump tweet about it
new dog city great level yeah now it's
the so that sort of like ode to the
original sort of Donkey Kong level well
you know first periods of Mario more or
less yeah no dr. Ellingham yeah and it's
uh it's a pretty resounding like moments
mmm like you sort of just you really do
like get once that happens you really
get the sense that that's what this is
this is just a massive celebration of
Mario's past did you find it a little
bit too self congratulatory no fireworks
the big song but that's the fun right
yeah I think so like that that's me
reminds me of something you'd see like
magical kingdom Disney World right you
know like the way they always advertise
that like come to Disney World and what
and they have that sort of thing going
on like it's just the the pageantry of
it always was really fun mmm like I
don't really think you ever see Mario as
you know Mario games like embraced
themselves in that way hmm you know seem
a games like self-aware lis embrace what
they are and what they've they've been
Mario obviously in general seems to be a
celebration of Mario games yeah almost
like resonable 7 was a Resident Evil
games mm-hmm
and Zelda was absolving games I guess
well no actually not at all yeah yeah I
think Justin started off this
conversation saying you know this has
been the year from the style Jo and yeah
like this game fully embraces its
nostalgia and I think that's why you
know it's connected with so many people
yeah but that's I I always whenever that
comes up want to reiterate that like
there is so much more to this game than
just nostalgia I mean it really is all
the you know the level design the the
dense and intelligent level design we
were describing earlier but it's also
there's that incredibly refined
mechanics that that that continued to
just prove that Nintendo knows better
than the rest when it comes to the sort
of things that Mario is capable of but I
can't think of a game that feels as good
like a 3d platformer and it feels as
good as as this and you could have said
that for a Mario Galaxy you could have
said that for a Myo 64 at the time and
they just you know they keep keep
dialing dialing in that that feel
there's no missteps even though they
added things if they're something that
feels broken or bad they they take their
time with their games and there's a
reason why I never noticed it before but
there's other ships like The Odyssey in
in the sky line oh yeah oh yeah like
half hot-air balloons mmm yeah that's
other place
if souls of other much that's an example
of yeah just exploring and finding stuff
or how did they get up here this snails
they just probably crawled up a song
[Laughter]
it's like an average-size I like that
they way can you look around skyline
quick it's a date they met on tinder
there no like oh okay so over there the
Chrysler Building is the tallest yeah
they just straight up use the Chrysler
Building
like straight well Empire State Building
is right behind you right yeah oh I did
not that was not calculated yeah
probably
to your point feed about just moving the
camera around right right yeah yeah like
here we were hmm
we had no idea let's just remember who
who led you to that it's getting
I don't need credit but it would be nice
was it you did you know it was there the
whole time yeah that was a real subtle
play it started off me saying I liked
the Chrysler Building is he tallest
building on the skyline but I forgot the
Empire State Building over here she's
not feeling the best looking this guy's
greater in New York
whoa controversial people be so pissed
let alone and Mario Odyssey is number
three Micah said Chrysler Building these
things so much what those fat seal
things no the pylons because I love
those fat seal things see why is that
one in the corner those are cute it's
like how will you get down I've never
been up so high I don't like Heights
either gonna get a Blair Witch Project
thing going on Mike that guy's name was
a Mike stared into the corner they did
that resi was seven - what's his name
characters after you know as duties he
looks like he's standing in the corner
that you go up and pull him in his face
was there a rusty pipe I don't think
they're gonna do that with Mario then
you'd be surprised what if they made
Mario into a horror franchise that'd be
a really big turn well you know they
have Luigi's Mansion
that was true yes
[Music]
I hated these mosquitos
I was only you're saying the the flick
sorry
so the so I play mostly with the joy con
but Peter was saying that you can do you
just flick from nowhere know your there
we go yeah well I mean try going like
you're throwing a frisbee you're doing
like a hole and then yeah people are
saying I mean one of the minor
criticisms at the beginning this some
people and was that it's too reliant on
earth like at some points it becomes to
realign our motive controls but you
could do that hats been you got an
analog there's like one or two things
that you can't do with just controls but
I find that argument [ __ ] because
look there's like a couple moons that
require you to do that yeah out of 833
if you're a completionist a
completionist is that what I said so it
sounded like you're just being defensive
um then I think you should take the five
seconds to do it and stop complaining
sorry it just seems like we can nitpick
about everything if we want to but
that's just like ignoring that nice and
please house yeah
what a dangerous building the sounder
can repair renovations it's just they're
saving life man
yeah if you go to it like some back
alleys in San Francisco it's exactly
like this something like this terrible
are you doing with this you're supposed
to be going up I'm going doing the
opposite direction all right so are you
have you guys gotten 999 moons is that
something that you're actually gonna try
for in this 833 833 is the max getting
999 dozen what Gaby
there's 999 now they're 100% 999 stars
or moons correct in really no not in the
world there aren't you have to buy them
oh that's the max number you can have
yes she bought them off yeah sure you're
right but I'm saying yeah what if you
buy a mile to the point that you get 999
and then you start finding other ones in
the world but it's thickened 99 huh yeah
and it's a hundred coins per moon right
yes yeah
makoy n--'s are not that plentiful do
you want to show off week like I know
you didn't watch other worlds like we
could have for John Luke bring it back
to us if you pick like toast arena town
might be a good one to show you want to
do that John Luke once we get to the
Odyssey could you come back to us on the
wide before we show toast arena town I
think you said yes you guys play much
into player man I mean roughly a little
bit and it's surprisingly different
obviously Cappy is his own sentient
character that said Clara can control
and that includes trolling Mario if you
really want to it's actually really fun
I'd be curious to do that in the long
run have you in Sebastian done what we
have been but I try not to do that
because he always makes me play Mario so
he can just to around this caffeine and
I'm trying to develop his skills you
know you got to make him a true gamer
yeah I pick him to chew gamer
[Music]
to catch what galaxy one of the best one
of the best moments I have in this game
was realizing that those little street
lights are actually yeah yeah we're
saying that galaxy
couch and play like co-op when you're
just I mean the second player just
literally collecting this yeah yeah no
they're just little scars alright yeah
if you can come back to the wide once we
go into the world select jean-luc okay
that's not good yeah 20 desert kingdom
that one was shown off as was the
all-city quite a bit so maybe something
didn't want to go some earlier like lots
Lost Kingdom or let's take a look like
it's yeah I kind of want to go to the
four letter one yeah what's the statute
of limitations on spoilers now I mean
like I said light spoiler warned I guess
boys uh how about we could also a lake
Kingdom
or what no can we do what in Kingdom
strictly for the music yeah what did
kill game you did what a kingdom we got
that down to that hidden area yeah with
the think we're good now to spoil like
you don't work is it this is a spoiler
what is the dark area yeah like when you
go down yeah I want to go down well it's
got the boss
well the the dinosaur yeah you mean
there's a bus oh he's up the boss that
you fight in the witty kingdom yeah no
no I'm talking about there's a there's a
secret place you can jump off a wall and
you end up in this like sub forest no I
think that's like a real dark yeah and
there's a there's an exclusive enemy
down there yeah that is actually you
don't want it you can ignore him but if
you try to embody him like he does
something cool but then you realize like
oh [ __ ] is that it's costing me to do a
screen fits this one right I think yeah
that's yes I just get this to learn what
I never so you can fall off anyway yeah
okay yeah yeah I learned that the hard
way or the easy way happened now deep
well it's John woods no it's no it's not
I don't think it's a big spoiler it's
just has he won the mains on this why
don't you yeah where is he
this was super eerie when you when I
first got oh yeah yeah it's so quite a
few up the phone again like the Beach
Boys soundtrack up on top it's a trap
there's a Star Trek trail you watch Star
Trek where is he's coming yeah this is
the coin coffer shaking this is a very
Jurassic Park look at the water
it's not really doing much but yeah that
coin guy yeah
you just follow him right you just fall
in mmm follow him does he eat well no I
mean you can take him over and use his
abilities as an attack but it is that
the cost of coins yeah really it's a
really fun thing to watch a really early
morning flight tomorrow I might just do
need to go play this person so I find
the coin convert Randy Hague over I
really want to do that I think yeah he's
over there
that's him he's from what I remember
he's like bottom-left of this map so I
actually know yeah like it keep heading
towards there he's around here somewhere
yeah there he is run from him go get him
oh that's who you're talking about
well listen Randy was referring to I
think but I'm talking about the coin
coffer it was literally like a change
purse he did him Danno
he cost you coins yeah he attacked me
explain it we can't show it yeah he's uh
he basically attacks by spitting out
coins but he uses your coins no I know
someone else that does that in a popular
franchise yes hmm
spoilers I'm not gonna say what is it at
all but so the yellow goombas why they
yellow down here cuz when you hit him
they pop out coins no son oh good that's
why have different pigments mm-hmm were
you at coin Crawford we're all yelling
no he's definitely down here somewhere
okay where is that I really like this is
my favorite no not this okay that dudes
when you shake they go up on the two
vines again yes
so like onions right something so good
yeah think I like bean stalks that come
out there like legumes with legs I want
to say he was around here like I'm not
even know where you are
mmm-hmm you can take control of him how
do you not just hat off I did it by
getting one of those destructible
platforms near the top of this level and
just getting him to attack those and
eventually he'll stun himself so first
you need to get his attention now we
might be wasting our time look at their
corn copper go get him I didn't have it
go get it by the way about you review
this right up it straight up nothing you
are not gonna make that do it again the
woman jump is one of my favorite things
in games the za you got ask you Amy
you may not think you doing that but
seriously do that again let's go back up
to the oil rig or whatever get that man
go back up for Pete for Pete save Oh
Mary you've lost your soul you're not
gonna make it I'm getting too old for
this
all right climb up climb up how do you
climb out right fine what the [ __ ] were
you through the seed there you just go
where'd you plant your seed good market
[Laughter]
get to old fish I want to hear that
music you Zack want to hear that baby
wouldn't wake up
my favorite song is in I think it's the
lost kingdom it's got this sort of
percussive timpani where the there those
guys rhythm to sort of offset but then
it like rejoins itself in harmonizes
it's super cool
go 1y enjoy I love these yeah these are
my favourite guys but when you're
climbing up the just the jump you do at
the end when you yeah what would you
call the facility like a logging thing
so know this sounds it flowers aren't
they aren't they aren't they growing
flowers isn't let the whole thing yeah
but this is all that metal that has to
do with anything I call it more funk
more funk yeah metal music what I think
we're talking about the oh god damn it
it was like once you went you go into
that hit and what you go into that
chimes and I love it there's bound to be
moons in there I really like these
levels let's see how completely defeated
this is where the game can get tough
yeah he's kind of spin off levels yeah
there's a one
I think it's called strange neighborhood
where the houses are tilting and you
have to go all the way to the end
throw Cathy back so you can't use them
afterwards to jump and then you have to
oh yeah you have to do goombas but you
have to get six of them by jumping back
across the houses was tough oh okay I
think it was in it was one of the saddle
bub rocket launchers into space from
toast arena town and speaking of
spoilers didn't actually get these
levels until you complete the game you
complete that well you complete this
story yeah yeah I'm talking about there
it is look out cleaning up worried well
not really actually he can get that last
cool hey you play this game in five
doesn't in this one doesn't like the big
Bullet Bill come from behind you in this
one stage yeah okay look behind you when
you when you get that key that bullet
came from the moon
don't you do it you dog but now just
showing off there is no taking take him
I'm sure you can take him home can take
him twice you can take him I thought
that iceberg okay hit him twice
well that defeat the purpose of level no
no because there's something at the
other end that you need him for
I could be incorrect but just try it
right yeah so I need to go back this way
nope straight straight be right there
now straight down there jump down
there's a okay
there's there's another moon underneath
that the blue structure there I think
that you could unlock
I think so yeah you need to aim can you
go off the x-axis with those bullet
bills can you change planes I don't know
like from what I recall I use that the
big dude to actually get there I know
there's a smaller one that comes can you
go down yeah you can there you go
you're not I know you can't I think
there's a different one at the end of
the other side
yeah whatever there's a different one
this is it yeah the big I guess you you
can go down on that side and that's
alright okay alright
oh well you did it catch elations Justin
this isn't my god I'm gonna collect
everything
do you have fun 25:20 like 100 I think
it's that you're only a 100 something
like that yeah you can technically
complete the story on 120 what is it
like what's the minimum you need from
that thing about with that around that
then the game is quickly like hey we
need 250 hey we need 500 yeah yeah and
500 is the last hurdle right in terms of
opening up the game right
[Music]
these guys are cool
glenda so many moons you haven't seen
yet well these are the is the extra ones
off to you
right but I got that one
I'm sure you got this one right
no because I think those would be
transparent Oh would they be transparent
if you're already collected Yeah right
good work just
these guys are the best yeah I like
climbing up that tower with them
the one thing that wish is that you
could take enemies in two different
worlds you could retain that power like
see what you can do with these guys and
you don't cry and again I'm sure we like
to boss fight at the end of this where
you have to use those onions I did not
like the new dog city tank boss fight it
was a bit arduous feel like it relied
too much on well I mean you could turn
it off but I feel like it yeah aiming I
don't know yeah is it the one with the
giant caterpillar yeah anal then yeah
but I liked the tanks when they first
given to you mm-hmm house I really like
these
[Music]
and there's another little mini boss at
the top of this is that right there's a
flying saucer
one of Bowser's minions dudes a bridal
party or whatever you wanna call them
the brutal the big rabbit thing yeah
we're trying to get to heaven oh yeah
you need fire to cook with how do you
there's a fire yeah if you go up the up
the side there but you can't get to it
from here there right what was that
sound doing just living in he's
screaming Oh singing a lot of characters
just staring at walls in this game
shower basically or watch geom shower a
bit of a lawyer now Rafael spider
actually there's one of the things I do
love about this game is when you do
complete it you see all these characters
who were just in their separate worlds
start moving around like they're
tourists yeah like toad
yeah really in the lake Kingdom when you
find toad at the bottom of that really
long tunnel or pipe and he just stuck
down there camping that's horrifying
you guys cool with it if you were gonna
swim up that high you'd have to hold
your breath well hey the pressure would
destroy your ears and your capillaries
but this is captain toad runt
yeah yeah I know I'm thinking too much
about it but it wanted me the
Australians say capillaries do you think
really really mm-hmm
capillaries are capillaries and our
caterpillars here also we pronounce
Australians like where's the car New
Zealanders they're like where's the car
I don't understand what you're saying
I'm from Australia it's from it's
frightening to clever coordinates okay I
guess we're now New Zealanders
Australians like where's the car New
Zealanders they're like and where's the
car
what am i doing it yeah this is where
you've been before right
yeah I actually flung myself over that
yeah at the top there is that other sort
of like flying saucer mini-boss thing
right okay yeah it's been a while can
you walk there to that flag work there
it's on the way I work there
up there I have fun with language - I'll
try and be more American for you guys
okay first tip no one says warp warp or
wire warp warp warp how do you think I'm
saying it right how do you want circular
bread donuts the less sweet ones bagels
are that good
are you a bagel person hell no those
people exist they are out there bagel we
never heard they say egg bagels we had
my way we would root them all out and
round them up and cover them and send
them to an island so sesame seeds and
poppy seeds and maybe I some I think I'm
feeling some bags I have not seen this
hungry uh-huh make your life more
difficult
yeah I was like quite good Oh a cinema
to splatoon
maybe you should which is Joey
pronounces splat tune yep
splat tune like two were to split tune
splitting careful split Seine split time
do you have to ask and I wanna be a
backseat driver why are you cleaning up
the paint business
oh that's right I was like you are
making a that's an edge so you need to
turn slippery
let's pray how that was poison could you
just me right emergency when you step on
yeah thank you right yeah triple-check I
think that was a glitch you should get
into it
[Music]
Queeny Bonni Bonni Bonni Bonni for me i
really do you guys want them to make
another mario game in the spain or do
you want them to go back to any old
style like I I feel like I'm not sure
like I want more of this but I need them
to go like really far out there in terms
of the the settings I'd be on board for
a sequel of this before they do
something else a little Mario with a one
to galaxy punch galaxy
do you like galaxy one or two better I
mean it's hard to compare them they're
kind of the same thing it's yeah I can't
she likes me yeah I think everyone
chooses to but I I personally have a
really hard time yeah saying that with
like any sort of logic what was it was
decadence usually like though like will
they now go to a 2d well a lot of years
sort of doing that
two and a half team mario thing yeah
before they got to world it did have
land well that's also with the 3ds now
it would have to be like it would be a
switch title soon right and i'm some
weird I mean I would hope Mario maker
comes to switch and that doesn't happen
I have to be so confused doesn't 100
sink like that but they do it Mario
maker too or just port the first 100
maybe - actually yeah probably - I think
that damn you're smart and we haven't
seen them do just straight ports at all
yet on the switch right like they've all
like Mario Kart 8 was more you're crazy
to London they've said Smash Brothers as
nothing's gonna be smashed it's of
Nintendo properties yeah yeah yeah I
mean they're closed they're closed I
mean they're mostly ports it's not like
they're remastered in a way that's
substantial but yeah like I just they
probably have to really before we get
anything like Mario maker they really
need to sort out their online
like and you got one right yeah there's
peach
what are you doing here peach so that's
that suitcase you got there you also
have one of those flying lizard guys up
here as well boilers what's spoiling
anything asking questions just peach who
cares yeah what you're saying Mario wins
in the end
yeah Bowser yeah man unheard of that is
a spoiler see from here you can like
anything you get that last get a good
flyby yeah could you do a little gliding
with the mr. Browdy sidecars name
what does he screech screech he's like a
baby pterodactyl he's kind of tough to
control I could have lost a little bit
yeah we have to lay it on a very
specific platform you that's it there
should be I think he's already got that
one you try for that good anyway yeah
[Music]
gonna make this know you might thank you
so much dear yeah you go along you don't
let go a jet what's that captain sir
no that's a toad that is kept you got me
just captain toad
[Applause]
yeah see he's always in these like traps
it's oh but but it's not like a
different toad every time so he's
clearly capable of moving your hand fro
you know stuff but how well there's a
pipe right here he knows how to control
the pipes but then you have to deal with
claustrophobia so you're coming around
here and you're like I found a new area
like no Kempton so it's already good
night is that the whole point of that
thing
just to get you to captain toad it's
gonna be another error that you can fly
to here right probably
I'll fly straight to that boss hmm 10
bucks that you smash into that fence
Bannerman
just kidding a flying saucer guy alright
maybe I just thought it a flying saucer
cause he's on this thing I would
probably it's a real jerk hat yeah I
shouldn't you should get out of that
stop jumping on goombahs start jumping
on goobers
[Music]
okay you got now you can do it all so
throw your head the spikes came despite
Falls I don't know that's the only way I
did it wanna calm in a stream let's do
it let's move on to our number two yeah
well yeah we got to take some time to
set up so we'll be back in a little bit
but Justin Randy thank you so much for
joining us thank you guys
get out see you around but uh yeah we're
gonna go back to just the standby screen
while we swap out for a couple more
guests and then we'll announce our
number two game so please stick around
we'll be back in like five ish minutes
see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everybody for real this time sorry
about the technical difficulties welcome
back to GameSpot's best for 2017
countdown we just announced the super
mario odyssey was our number three game
of 2017 as its cited on by GameSpot
staff I won't keep you waiting to get
into this montage of a game that I'm
sure will surprise everyone let's do it
[Music]
trickster
[Music]
welcome to my Velvet Room
[Music]
it's not a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I am thou thou art I thou hast acquired
a new vow it shall become the wings of
rebellion that break it by chains of
captivity
[Music]
[Applause]
persona 5 from Atlas is our number 2
game of 2017 so I brought on a bunch of
persona 5 fans Michael hi I'm yo John
Luke sucky jumped off the track acid you
come talking about yeah and there's
always Peter Brown I'm still here and
yeah a lot of people argue pretty
vehemently for this game Michael you
were one of them why disability on our
number two spot Oh a lot of reasons I'll
tell you that
start with one okay I'll start with the
themes it tackles okay so the persona
five is very much about authority
figures about people in power who abused
their power and influence in very
devious ways and you know as these
Japanese high school students you put
your foot down and you say no you're not
getting away with that [ __ ] and that's
that's very powerful within itself but
it the premise gets deeper and deeper
and what you soon realize as you it
sprinkled out through throughout the
game but it kind of builds up to this
notion that you know society's problems
go much deeper than individual people
like they can be like like very shitty
people they can do terrible things but
like it goes deeper than that like only
one person has so much power and then
what you soon kind of realize is that
you know as a society as a collective
group of people you know you have to you
know do something about it if you want
to make changes and that's kind of a
central theme to the game as you know
fighting for change and then you know I
was playing yesterday and there's this
moment where Morgana asks the main
character the cat your sidekick yeah
sidekick the teddy figure I suppose in
persona 5 even better than teddy yeah
yeah I definitely ground that but he
asks you something and he looks at you
and says why don't people do anything
about the bad things that happen in this
world and you have three answers and
like they can't they don't have the
power to or they don't care or they like
that it's not beneficial to them to act
out or they're lazy that's that's pretty
much the most universal human tree yeah
that's
yeah no I just said but like John Luke
over the course of the game as you're
actually going into the so like the
premise is like you as phantom thieves
you have the power to essentially go
into people's minds their subconscious
their kind of their mental layout and
you get to change their hearts so to
speak but they're divided into separate
dungeons in each person it's almost like
you're diving into each person's psyche
how do those dungeons play out of the
course of the game or they how are they
creatively laid out do they kind of
morph over the course of game what do
you think of them yeah I mean they kind
of take a different approach the past
percent of games have been using sort of
like a randomized layout dungeon yeah
procedural dungeons and this game yeah
they're much more intentionally laid out
and I almost kind of akin them to
sometimes they have like a Dark Souls
sort of like spiral kind of loop design
yeah where you have the save points and
then as you're going through the game
you will either get new save points or
sometimes you'll unlock shortcuts that
go back to like the same end point
there's this one dungeon that has like a
central kind of like long chamber and
then each one kind of keeps looping back
into that Center so they do clever
things like that to kind of keep the
dungeon layout interesting compared to
the previous games yes but a lot more
like puzzles yeah and some stuff and I
this is my first persona game ever but
it was one of my favorite games out of
2017 but it did remind me of like a
traditional Zelda dungeon kind of like
how each of them are specific theme like
we're gonna play one in a little bit
livestream like a bank vault it's laid
out like a bank vault and like the
dungeon itself starts rearranging and
like more modern Zelda's leaving breath
of the wild aside the dungeons do kind
of loop back in on themselves if it's
like a puzzle box dungeon if you watch
like Marc Brown stuff about them on
YouTube but what about the combat here
Michael as far as figuring out certain
enemies weaknesses like you know like
personae are actual are like the things
you can control each person has their
own and the Joker the main character he
can control a bunch of them you capture
them or and then you can actually use
them against the ones you've encounter
in these dungeons or in mementos the be
kind of just like for that's procedural
and so far as that's what you're doing
between dungeons but how was the combat
affect your notion of the game as you're
going through it so this was also my
first game in the line of Shin Megami
Tensei
games but it's it's essentially at the
foundation it's a very similar combat
system as you seen in previous SMT games
and persona games but it's it's very
much refined in this way that you know
it's when you're in battle especially
tough battles it's almost trying to
figure out a puzzle like okay this
character like in any really good
turn-based RPG you kind of have to
figure out okay whose turn is it next do
I need to heal a certain person who
might be attacked or buff their stats
and/or can I hit this particular enemy
enemies weakness so I can get another
turn or give it to someone else like tag
them yeah and you can do a baton pass
and pass it someone else if you have
your social linked high enough or
confidant yes nice feeling when you oh
yeah well I want to talk about compounds
the best feeling when you you have like
four different enemies and you use like
a shock weakness on one pass it off to
someone with a fire attack and then you
actually just passed baton like four
times you just keep going infinitely
until they're dead yes of the knowing
the enemy's weakness is kind of the the
key key part of this particular
turn-based system because you get that
extra turn and you can knock them down
and you know it's and sometimes you just
can't you can't even figure out their
weakness as well especially lost battles
so then you kind of have to think okay
well if I don't have that in my back
pocket you know who do I need to buff
what items can I use to make sure that
you know my characters don't die or I
can boost them so they can be even more
damage before that enemy has their turn
so it's this constant puzzle that you
have to figure out and then throughout
between the dungeons you're preparing
for each dungeon almost like you might a
heist you're kind of planning out we're
gonna go in like this like you're just
you're building your team and then
you're also developing confidence I want
to ask Michael about that but the
everyday life in this Tokyo setting John
Luke when you're going between like
batting cages or going to eat burgers or
and everything you're doing is
increasing your social stats how does
that part of the game complement the
dungeons in a combat like this you know
I would assume before I played the game
that this would be the boring part but
that's not the case in this game no I
mean I think there's a lot of people who
like prefer this part like put the game
on easy because this is the part of the
game they like to experience I think
they integrated a lot better in this one
so in previous persona games you
would talk to your social links for
confidants and you would basically as
you rank up with them it allows you to
create more powerful personas which you
can give us you boost in combat but in
this one they have more tangible
benefits as well where okay I want to
hang out with this politician who is on
the screen right now and then doing so
actually increases my chances of talking
to the shadows and getting being able to
like get more personas eventually you
can do more benefits like that like
there's characters there's amazing
social link that I wish I'd done more of
because this person gives you the
ability to swap party members mid-battle
yeah which open it sounds like not chess
but she's the show or game show do you
play fresh channel should be playing
yeah but like opening that up gave me
like a whole new like suite of options
yeah in the combat like all of a sudden
like okay now I can I can try and like
manage my SP better by being like well I
can swap this character out with this
character this one's weak and that
becomes like really critical and boss
battle so I think they do a lot better
job just like providing more for
incentive to do their social links and
then just like that in turn like makes
the combat like way more dynamic yeah
and you mentioned you touched on
negotiations actually I wanna talk about
those because that's you don't always
have to fight people in fact a lot of
times there are enemies you're better
off negotiating with talking with you
actually I mean you do start I think
you'e mentioned like you do start to see
through the cracks of how they work like
specific characters you see the
connection between what they say yeah
yeah I will say that still was a good
change of pace from the fighting like
figuring out oh they just said this so
that means they're kind of insecure so
then your next answer the follow-up
almost you have to play on that in order
to either become friends with them and
make them trust you or make them
intimidate them it's almost like a
psychoanalysis that makes the the combat
like a not secondary but it is a good
change of pace from the combat yeah it
keeps it interesting yeah what about the
negotiations did you were you doing
those often throughout the game oh I
really like doing all-out attacks so
negotiations were kind of my secondary
option but you know you can juice them
for like even more money as well like as
you get better speech skills from anime
Bernie Sanders yep and there you can
you can actually extort more money out
of the enemies so if like man I'm low on
yen but I want to buy a new equipment
for my from my party it's like you know
I'm just gonna keep asking that for more
and more money I didn't really use the
ones with the one where you can ask them
for items like I was just like ask for
money to buy the items that I want and
then like you know wielding their power
to create more personas yeah it's almost
like this Pokemon esque kind of you know
structure in that when you capture their
persona you can hinge their abilities or
you can fuse them in a very vicious
manner when you go to the Velvet Room
you literally like line them up on
guillotines chop their heads on behind
them to get like what is hanging them do
hanging them transfers scalar power to a
different person to another persona it's
it's quite it's pretty dark yeah yeah
like The Velvet Room in general is
always creepy as hell with a Gore egora
dude the main voices he's insisting
character from the game since the first
game yeah but like as your brilliant
confidant John Luke you're built some of
them become party members we don't have
it on the B screen right now but in our
room we see like Makoto used to used to
K use K used to K and then on well this
get in my defense this game now the game
says you say that's the one they get
right okay whatever but in my defense
this game did not help me with my
Japanese but uh yeah it's more hussain
told me i would be dead to him if i
didn't mention and agree with him that
makoto is best girl she sure is man yeah
she's the student council president and
then like Britt starts breaking out of
that touch pronounce Makoto starts
breaking out of that show I'll let you
guys pronounce the names from now and
I'll just I'll give it all that color
commentary but uh she's like you're
developing these confidants some of them
just let any skills Brothers become
party members and thematically and
narrative Li it's interesting how
they're real I know this is nothing new
for the series but I really enjoyed how
the parts of them that they suppress
despite the fact that it really does
kind of dictate their personality come
out in the in these in the phantom world
whatever you want to call it whatever's
yeah meta first I was gonna say upside
down just
maura thing but did you uh did you have
any favorite characters or like what was
it like building the relationship for
these characters you actually feel
connected with them or did you feel like
it was just a game if I'd kind of thing
now you definitely feel connected with
them especially like because the game
lets you choose like which ones do want
to continue like developing further so
it's like okay like I'm actually pretty
invested in macchiatos like relationship
with her sister and I can't want to
explore that further in the game helps
you so the game kind of like you get the
stuff through the main story and you you
get to kind of experience these
characters and but then also the game
lets you like choose which ones you kind
of want to like continue to explore and
get to know better and I mean you know
this game's long it's like a hundred
hours but by the end of it you like I
think the length works as far as like
developing that relationship with those
characters like it wouldn't mean nearly
as much watching if it was just like a
20-hour thing or like a like a movie
like they're doing an anime of it and
the anime like they did one for four as
well and it was a good anime but you
don't get that same connection that you
do like putting a hundred hours into
these characters and deciding where to
develop the relationships actly yeah so
you you as the player get to you feel
like this is your connection to the
characters and like you said when you I
played my first playthrough is 120 hours
and when you get to like sit on those
story beats and the development
developments of the relationships you
know you get to stop and think about
this you know things aren't always
happening you get to stop and smell the
roses for yeah lack of a better term and
I think that helps the character
development it helps you you know care
about your core cast and everyone else
that you kind of helps you along the way
and you know I I really felt connected
to this to this game and then it made me
want to go back and play the other
persona games and see what they had to
offer and you know those things are
there as well I feel feel very connected
to the cast of four and three and you
know five being able to portray that
even better and motivate someone to go
back in the series is quite powerful to
me and while we're watching the b-roll
just the sheer amazing [ __ ]
presentation in this game between the
soundtrack
transitions you live you use a few of
them in your montage that you did that
video earlier that we watched and just
everything about it just exudes like
style it's just the most confident game
ever and immediately it hooks you it
right away I'm just super into the
universe I'm like when I first start
playing was like whether I like this
game or not I respect what they're doing
right now and I ended up loving it was
one of my favorite games of 2017 but the
more I played it the more like they just
like even like the characters like when
you meet specific characters the way
that they're these screens and the
loading screens and the attack screens
like the all out attacks change for
whoever initiates the all-out attack
based on like like Ryu G's will be like
a lot of punk stuff
speaking of for Yugi I do want to get
into it I did not like we usually at
first but this kind of encapsulate why I
love this game throughout I did a video
essay earlier in the year about why this
reignited my love for like Japanese
style RPGs I absolutely loved how it was
constantly subverting my expectations
and messing with RPG tropes in general
like Ryu G starts out as this angry punk
kid it's Brett yeah he's a brat and then
you start to figure out like you start
to hear his backstory and of course like
it's nothing new making you empathize
the characters you might not think you
might but really became my favorite
character in the game outside of like
people you meet later on but it was just
the way it actually subverted like it
never felt like I was grinding even
though you kind of do have to at certain
points something when it comes to
mementos you might have to but I just
never felt like I was wasting a day
despite the fact that was time
management and this game was so good at
subverting JRPG narrative tropes and
gameplay tropes and like just RPG tropes
in general that it was constantly
keeping me guessing like I don't know
that any other game has do you find the
same thing Michael yeah definitely I
I've played a lot of JRPGs in my time as
well I grew up on them at a very young
age but here this is different because
you almost have this like social
simulator part to it which is kind of
what what drives you to care about this
world in many ways and then so you know
you meet these characters first and then
you kind of have an initial impression
but of course you dig deeper and you
learn about their desires what drives
them and you know for example you said
were you GU kind of like once you get to
the end of his social link you kind of
understand like why he is the way he is
and like how he can be better even
like Mikoto her initial intro in the
game is that she's like a a plus student
who's like a teacher's pet and stuff but
she's very conflicted even early on in
the game you know between her sister and
then akechi who's like like being a like
really smug to her and then how the
Phantom fees initially was like you know
she's just trying to get us caught up
she's a snitch and then she's like
nobody accepts me I'm trying my best
yeah like I'm trying my best but nobody
accepts me but I do have this desire to
instill justice and I think that by way
of the Phantom thieves
I'm going to join them and express
everything that I've been feeling since
she was a kid because if you go into her
backstory and her father and all that
it's like she finally unleashes that
inner passion yeah and she joins her
party and that's part of why you care
about these characters like their
stories within themselves aren't like
revolutionary but when you have like 10
15 of these stories all put together
driving to the same goal I think that's
what makes persona fight cast and
characters and story very special and
like a certain point in the game it
starts to ask whether what you're doing
is actually just and righteous I mean
like a lot of superhero tales do that
and you're essentially like psychic
superheroes in this game to be reductive
but you actually it starts to question
whether you're not the bad guys you are
going to people's minds and screwing
with their wiring to make them better
people so to speak and like a lot of
them admit their guilt and do become
better people but there are like
implications that come with that like is
this even moral to do that do you think
the game did a good job making you
question your own actions throughout
John Luke oh definitely at the end I
mean they really start to get into that
I would say the game maybe doesn't at
the end it is sort of like still like no
we still did the right thing and I and I
I guess that comes down to like how your
personal perspective because I felt like
yeah I think they did the right thing -
um but the game definitely does make you
question that like the characters have
like this you know crisis of faith about
what they're doing is right and sort of
yeah like the realization that kind of
like were you talking about that it's
just like society as a whole it's the
problem and that like you know it's not
just about we can change we we have to
force this change on people it's we need
to get people to realize to make the
change them so
it's kind of like the larger theme of
the game and yeah not definitely not
OneNote like it does sprinkle that a
little bit of doubt but then by the end
you like kind of for your thing is that
like no how we doing the right thing
yeah and that's a really good feeling
too because when when the whole cast
securities that you care about kind of
realize and then when you go into this
game that has so much style so much
confidence like even though main
characters like smirk and like every
time he does like the all-out attack and
stuff like that just like wow I really I
really believe in what they're doing and
what I'm doing along with them would you
name your main character I I did a shout
out to the Giant Bomb persona for
endurance really okay yeah Charlie - no
no that's my boy yeah I named him Akira
because that's the that's a manga name
for him so I've got there's more though
persona 5 one of the more memorable
games of this year stylistically
narrative Lee and the ways it's
subverted its gianna it was one of my
favorite games of the year and a lot of
the GameSpot staff happen to agree so
that's why I got to our number 2 spot if
you're watching this on GameSpot or
YouTube after the fact please go catch
up on our first eight games that we've
announced is that right we're on number
this is the ninth game we've announced
but it's number two yes so go catch up
with all those you can watch our
discussions and our live streams which
we've archived playing those games if
you're watching this live we are going
to be talking about our number one game
of the year which I'm sure nobody knows
what it is but we're gonna be talking
about that in a little while so stick
around if you want to watch us live
stream persona 5 Michael's got a ps4
controller somewhere in the room I will
throw it oh it's right next to him sweet
we're gonna be playing that right now so
hang out unless you don't want something
spoiled this is if you happen to be
anywhere before the third dungeon
correct yes yes sir this is the third
dungeon this is connoisseurs palace and
I chose this because it has the best
palace music yeah let's talk about that
but I like this is the best palace
layout and my level design in my opinion
unless I'm forgetting one that its major
one I have to say I cannot stand the
space though we both didn't mind the
space I I think it was just
MacDonald when she came for e3 me and
her talking about it I I abhorred it
like it was it angered me but I still
see what I was going for
yeah but anyway this one's fantastic I
think we can agree on that okay yeah
yeah we got now you saved this girl
good I was kind of put off by the fact
that maybe they lead you to believe that
you can romance Yusuke late as you go
freely nice so I found that a little
frustrating yes they definitely feel
like they're leaning into that and he
looks exactly like a character from
persona 2 who is a gay romance option so
the fact that he looked exactly like
that character and they're like hinting
at it I was thinking they were gonna go
that do that again and I was like Oh
that'd be great because they haven't
done that since - that's weird that they
didn't they didn't do it they were
actually almost did in four but then
they ended up cutting it I don't know
why III got onto max level
I liked her story eat it on yeah yeah
yeah she's dope she's my primary damage
dealer alright we're gonna get into a
family go ahead my damage dealer was you
can make her front no I would use magic
damage dealer for sure fire attacker God
is music oh I was telling you earlier
when we did our mom the forward air
Odyssey stream that I'm like dangerously
considering replaying this game not that
it doesn't deserve to be at all but like
it's just it's I'm devoting another 90
hours that I could use to clean up the
rest of my back dog over the holidays or
I would even recommend like go play for
that's probably a better idea as well I
think it's a better idea cuz well I
think these games I don't like for real
like what oh I find this game is so much
more interesting from the get-go
for at least like jumping into for it
takes a lot of effort and patience with
that
so for me I'd the characters before
ended up I be more attached to them by
the end and I think that's because I
don't to say it's a little bit of a
smaller story in for that's kind of more
about the town and about these cameras
more about it's about people and yeah
this game does um blow up as you play
exactly it kind of becomes like a larger
Seidel societal promoted because that
takes away the focus from the characters
and I do think that fight is certainly
the best playing like mechanically they
make a lot of really smart changes but I
do think three and four is still worth
playing because each of them tell a very
different story and have very different
characters that all feel unique and are
worth experiencing yeah I went back and
played for this year and after I
finished four I kind of asked myself do
I like like and I when I finished five
is like this is a very special game to
me and but I played for I was like whoa
I have a conflict here I don't know if I
like four or five more they do very
things very differently though but when
I came out of it and actually like
thought about it I think I'd give the
edge the edge two four and then so then
I asked myself like it's persona for my
favorite game of all time and since I
was like 12 I said that the original
deus ex is my favorite game of all time
so i was like very well yeah go back and
play the original Deus Ex I did like to
use fantastic game they killed it but
it's a very very important game but I
would I would rather replay if I was mad
and I haven't played fun for is but the
best way I played on Vita Gold Edition
oh yes yeah played on the Vita TV if you
have it definitely play on your TV the
difference between gold and just normal
were there so they added a couple new
social links a bunch of new events make
some changes to the combat new item it's
a lot for like a special edition like
they've always kind of gone really the
extra mile whenever they like do a
remake like they just announced they're
doing a Catherine
yeah like remaster which is by persona
people they made it and it's not just
like a simple port like they're adding a
whole new character they're gonna add
multiple Hong Catherine full body full
body but they're guys like a new
character and all this other stuffs like
they they always go the extra mile with
their special editions which is really
cool so I still gonna ask you guys
anything I know the answer but here
should Megami Tensei you guys played any
of those games before I do want to get
into it but I so yeah that's probably
like the big weak spot for me cuz
yeah that's it's a very different I love
them they're very different because it's
not so much about these interpersonal
relationships it is about you versus
like the fate of the world and like
ultimate good and evil so persona always
sneaks that in at the end and I would
say that's actually a detriment to
persona in the sense that like the
context of what it says exactly it kind
of sets up this like personal
relationship and then they're like
Megami Tensei stuff comes in at the very
end and it feels a little out of place
at times it gets dark fast like wall
three in particular gets is pretty much
a darker one of three I think
earns it I think it's more for and sure
five yeah at the end kind of feels like
it's thrown in because it's like well
it's a technically Megami Tensei game
right yeah I mean the any Shin Megami
Tensei game there's like nothing cute in
it whatsoever there's nothing where
you're like oh that really warm my heart
like now they're very it's it's wait
totally just in a different ballpark and
shimming intensity three Nocturne I
think you can play on ps3 as a ps2
classic yeah I guess looks incredible is
that the one you would recommend playing
absolutely I mean for apocalypse on 3ds
is very very good maybe more accessible
if you don't have a ps3 set up because I
don't think you can play Nocturne on ps4
and even just a standard Shin Megami
Tensei 4 on 3ds is great but apocalypse
kind of actually adds a bit more modern
style to it and tells the story a little
bit differently I mean it is a new set
of characters and everything it's it's
like roughly the same events I mean all
the shipping intensity games are kind of
similar in terms of the bigger reason
that things are happening right but
Nocturne is just the epitome of well
it's tough actually because Nocturne is
very style it stylish but then so too
are the digital devil saga games the the
pair that came out after that but in a
very different way
yeah but then you've also got the Rhino
cousin cousin ooh ha if I'm a memory
that name devil right Devil Summoner
there two or three of those on ps2 I
mean you could you could spend hundreds
of hours playing excellent games if
Dobin to the ps2 should make me tense a
lie so that's something I'm potentially
excited for us cuz they did so many ps2
games like you said and they they all
had like they use the same like shared
pool of assets like all the you know
pretty much the personas and demons in
the Megami Tensei games are like all the
same pretty much so because they've kind
of made them all in like these really
nice like 3d models of the original art
I would love to see Megami Tensei game
like use the persona like assets as a
way to like like I want to see like
those games like fully realized in 3d
the way first out of five is I think
would be kind of cool they know the news
which can Megami Tensei while oh yeah I
mean the ps2 games are 3d no no I know
but at like um I think there was a what
I'm saying is that the 3d models on the
ps2
we're like never quite fully captured
like the 2d art like us so when you look
at the menus you can see like oh here's
what they originally drew that sure
human as okay so there's a 3d model
right and it's it's like close but
you're like all the limitations of the
ps2 these look like they spent a lot of
effort trying to capture the original
art yeah because they can 3d to see them
what got me tensed I understand I
understand yeah and I think five is
probably gonna be an exam sure sure is
out that's was it's Shin Megami Tensei 5
I'm yeah it's kinda so yeah that's
become a thing we're like personas
pretty much always been a PlayStation
series and then like Megami Tensei is
now kind of like stayin on Nintendo
systems for last couple years well it
was born on Nintendo right original
Famicom yeah cuz were the series begin
but it's got interested in keeping doing
that there and not although I'd like to
see honestly I think they should just be
on every platform like persona 5 should
be on the switch it'd be cool if they
brought I'm gonna bring it to switch I
don't know the replay
Tokyo sessions sharp Fe they should put
that on they should put that on switch
that it came out to wait a little more
persona ish yeah
Shin Megami Tensei 3 Nocturne yeah that
cs3 port of three is the piece is that
just the stuff it's okay it's a ps2 game
that they may need a class
like on PSN yeah and then it became
Nocturne no that was always a 3t it was
always that was always the subtitle yes
Oh gotcha okay I thought it was like a
hold situation it's a it's an emulated
version of the ps2 yeah in case three
alright so here I put on put on the yeah
so commie uniforms yeah
oh you gonna get that meet the battle
music - yeah I got time to make history
as well is that the persona for uniform
yeah yeah I school there at yeah you
can't see but we're both wearing y'all
Sagami sure yeah we're repping my old
high school high so what about in three
three what the whoa Tector just happened
whoa well told you this game was stylish
we're gonna fix that what did this
Playstations turn on it's probably a
video issue it's a like a sync problem
look at the barrel should we ender just
try to fix this tag what do you want it
you wanna well we'll give them them and
we could talk about all right yeah nice
straight up Peter it's interesting like
I on forum you go on the internet and
and you look up state in it no it's
terrible you know you should never go
there it's a society subconscious and
you go into it exactly change their
minds and be like no but sometime it's
really good Star Wars last Jedi it's not
well I was saying is um you always see
this like divide between like persona
people and shimmer grammar tends to
people and specifically like I think she
Megami Tensei I definitely wanna get
into it but they always seem like very
curmudgeon II about it in a way where
and I'm not subscribed to me yeah
they're always like these like casual
fans and their and their social sins and
their persona people at me and they they
don't know true Shin Megami like they're
so I mean to see mrs. a broadly I think
they're probably scared of the idea of
like falling in love with characters you
know what I mean like having an
emotional connection to someone like you
guys do with the characters in these
games yeah shaming me tensed does not
concern itself with endearing you to
these people right there are characters
and character moments and some story
arcs but it's not the point
no totally I think they're scared of
that asshat it's just that's always
weird to me because I'm just like guys
we're these were all fans of this
incredible
pretty nischala even persona it's very
niche so it's like why can't we all just
be happy that all these games are
complete here so again I think maybe the
worry was like oh persona would overtake
in the comments it certainly has it has
in terms of public reception but maybe
like oh they're not gonna make a new
Shin Megami no no no but but but that
fear was certainly there and maybe
people just didn't direct it
appropriately ya know it did seem for a
while with all the hype about for I was
like no one ever talks about shaming me
Tensei and that's kind of upsetting
because I always always was always
thinking like when is the series gonna
get it today and persona did kind of
take it out from under it that's fair
that's that's a but later but I think
certain but I think when five comes I
don't switch that's going to be a good
point where both sides can really look
at the two and say do I prefer one
together or do I like both I know I
think there's room in my heart for both
I'm not surprised that people are
defensive of property if they love well
for me it's weird where it's like
they're technically part of the same
series and it's like I don't know for me
for me I'm just like can we be happy
that we're both getting like these weird
niche games that we love but Easter eggs
and like oh it has to be better than the
other between Shin Megami Tensei and
persona oh yeah definitely
oh there's similar characters and
enemies and stuff all the carried on
through yeah you'll always see Jack
Frost yeah yeah they're all pretty much
the same they just refer to them as a
demons in Megami Tensei yeah love to see
persona 5 come to switch be good yeah it
was late they so originally they said
like no before the game came out but
then a while back they put out like a
like a fan poll of like what would you
like to see and it was like a bunch of
lists like for some firefighting game
like a special edition one of them was a
switchboard oh we're good alright sweet
let's get back when it's in the back
room we can get back to playing this
game for another five minutes or so he's
a little longer that's it you just want
to stay here all day yeah sure yeah
let's do that
we're not even gonna announce our game
of the year anymore no I'm just kidding
now we're just gonna okay we good yeah
oh I'll use that Mikoto ready to rock
Mikoto what do you very much market oh
macha tough
wait the schools not we anything yet
that was stuck with the disappointment
about this game that the big criticism
I'd put on it is that the localization
is a pretty weak spots and it's weird
because I think for is is really really
good so I think download the Japanese
voice acting which everybody who likes
the game a lot would recommend but well
that doesn't even fix it though because
a lot of its in the text you know the
more on this game's text so that
wouldn't necessarily fix your your
issues with oh yeah localization and I
think I don't know what was going on
there I don't speak Japanese and even I
knew it was bad compared to like four
because four was so good but did they
redo anything between the original ps2
release of four and the golden they
added a bunch of new in terms of yeah
like localization wise like there maybe
maybe they had hindsight to kind of go
back did they tweak anything I don't
know they did have to redo a character
because I'm her voice actress like quit
voice acting so they had to retire
ga-ga-ga Marilyn but I don't know if
they ever made sweeping changes I was
actually thinking about that about
because I I guarantee you a special
edition of persona 5 will probably
happen just by the track record of them
doing it with every other persona game
at some point and if they do I'd be
curious if they would actually take the
effort to read localize it or if that's
way too much work and money it's
definitely a lot of work and money yeah
so I don't know if that is worth it but
I'd be into that
have we seen the overall like a puzzle
box nature of this dungeon yet no it's
pretty young this is the probably the
area oh really talk about the locks once
you get down to the Knights in the
second half
yeah it's gotcha so I like that part a
lot let's do some quick social stuff
yeah
or well yeah run around play yahooza and
I love that game for the same reason I
love this game like just like that
encapsulating like an aspect of like
Japanese like culture and the ability to
like interact with it and like walk
around and turn-based strategy with yeah
turn-based strategy I mean we certainly
don't know how accurate it is but it
feels authentic anyway right exactly
just like that like slice-of-life kind
of totally yeah there's something
special about that I think anybody who's
played persona 5 ends up wanting to have
jokers bedroom don't know about that
decorator this place ever every time you
walk into a deal that old I don't know
if so mineral becomes a very good
character towards the end I believe it I
mean I know he's got good intentions and
what don't know what that's like
everybody's dream oh man maybe not my
dream with the market oh it's sick it's
huge dude go downstairs for curry and
coffee that does sound pretty dope maybe
the bathroom in the making yeah I know
but they eat it all the time in this
game half waiting I didn't know that was
a thing is that thing in Japan curry and
coffee I've never heard of those two how
is that what LeBlanc is yeah curry shop
with coffee as well like halfway through
playing this game I was just like yeah I
can retire and run a coffee shop and
yeah those small comments but watch it I
don't know that I can pull it off but
now I'd never be that weirdo that weird
white guy because it hurts no to just
set up shop in Tokyo where I took you
with heed last September he was telling
me about this Australian dude he moved
to Japan
and literally set up a cafe in his
garage like not to like me close to
Akihabara like sort of outside from like
the nerdy shopping parts of it and then
went there nice it was packed some white
guy exactly does you guys just described
having that dream can come true that's
true and you know I guess to be fair
that would actually probably be an
advantage because it's like okay well
there's there's lots of cafes all over
it
you know Tokyo but this one's run by
like this Australian guy like that's
cool right the one where we can exploit
the owner and well part of it is a
coffee in Australia is like super is
taken super seriously and so he brings
over that quality and knowledge sure
that's part of it too yeah like you have
to be you have to bring something to the
table
yeah I've only been to Japan once when I
throw sock out with some more and Adam
former UK team Tamura was talking about
how he wants to like it would be dope to
retire there and just live there
afterward to keep your mind sharp and
still like I kind of figure out a new
culture that you'll never just like
fully understand don't do it in Tokyo
yeah I don't know where you why it's
Tokyo just impossible to figure out ah
it's just it's it's too much yeah it's
way too much something like Kyoto is I
mean this is their one of a couple of
many places in Japan I'd rather go to
Kyoto before I go yeah let's go to the
arcade girl hell yeah we show you how to
play videos we keep going next summer
for us I am a graduation thing or
something yeah my brother graduation
gift we're going to Japan first time I
liked it a lot
I've not been nearly as much as Pete or
Justin or and he goes a lot for the
Australian team more people have lived
there they know it a little better than
me probably I'll just show up and start
telling people to yo I got this good
place you gotta check out
yeah so here we are this is the opening
social link event or confidante event
for enjoyment so take it to the arcade
man hey y'all taking notes right now
this is how you win a girl's heart man
take her to your game yeah we gonna play
sometime crisis right now so maybe you
need notes no watching those right now
is this that this is the different arc
don't you go to a key I brought a meet
what's his name later the kid yeah
that's a different case not a Christian
no not me sure about it he talkin about
the kid who gives you the range
oh yeah the the tower confidant yeah I
didn't find his skills that he give you
useful
oh no the his first ones super useful
because basically you have a chance of
starting the battle where you can like
just rain like he'll have that one then
there's another one in there yeah I like
that because like you essentially can
get like up to like a force of some
enemies help off like they're from the
stars they're weak to guns you can look
down a bunch of them can you not well
you also get another ability where you
can you'll use up most if not all of
your bullets sure but you will
automatically down an enemy we regard
gamer
there's one of their weak monologue
which is like a really good like um like
in a pinch me that a lot of people with
a lot of personas with wings or a weak
two bullets like the all those fairy
type creatures tightly in for I spend a
lot of time trying to like figure that
out where I'm like okay well that that
demons at our table so is he weak to
fire and then it's like when it's like
oh no you knock the table down with wind
so it's wind like massive yeah and then
it's like well at tables read so you
know that one's water and then you run
into a towering penis and then you have
no idea sexual overtones in a wheelchair
yeah
metaphor is abound okay that's a
metaphor here I think it is no it's
pretty literal Weiner on wheels
your ideas thank you oh yeah that's
right I look forward to so I named him
main character Kenji after my cat when I
started the game my cat only has one eye
and it just so happens that whenever
that dude's profile pic comes up he's
like the light it's pretty good
incidents in oh no let's let's take my
finger in your ear was the Sicario see
the trailer for the second one six they
need Vil news I also like the the story
rapper they have them this one where it
starts out at a certain point in the
future and it kind of keeps coming back
to that moment yes being interrogated
yeah I think my staggered as hell I just
started watching again last night
true detective it starts during
interrogation in the present and then
they're telling the story about the past
and then it meets up with the present
and then you continue into the future
that's what I just said yes oh I thought
you were I thought you were correcting
me I just said that anyway but like
we're going forward especially three
sometimes you get into the grind and
it's like easy to like lose like the
larger picture where it's like oh I've
spent like a couple weeks just like
doing social stuff and you're kind of
like forgetting the overall so like I
think this narrative is like a good way
to like remind you like alright there's
like this bigger picture that's gonna
like keep cropping up yeah this frame
story
yeah options really well I think it it
makes a lot of sense you say you want to
call it stream yup move on to our number
one soon all right cool everybody who's
watching live right now don't go
anywhere we are gonna go to standby
quick get a few different cast members
on to talk about our overall game of the
year but yeah persona five number two as
voted on and argued by many of the
GameSpot staff let's go through them one
more time see if I'm still on the ball
number ten Nier automata nine was what
remains to be at Finch
eight was hell blade said it was
sacrifice seven Wolfenstein two new
Colossus six horizon zero dawn five
divinity original sin - four where's
evil seven three Super Mario obviously -
or sort of five and who knows what
number one's gonna be so stick around
we'll be right back
see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to GameSpot's best of 2017
countdown it is finally time to announce
our game of the year you just saw that
montage if you didn't just tune in right
now you saw our games 10 through 2 we
just played a little bit of persona 5
with Michael Hyman Jean Luc's and now we
have Justin hey Walt hey in Rob Henry
how are you and Peter Brown as always we
are let's just jump right into I'm sure
none of you have any idea what game or
about the show but let's show you anyway
what's it gonna be
hey we're still here but we'll show you
[Music]
quick uplink
[Music]
once again so you're finally awake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
so surprising everyone The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild is GameSpot's
overall a game of 2017 Rob Hammond are
you kind of like this game yeah kind of
curveball right yeah it's alright Justin
you too yeah I never saw this coming
what we do in this game is freakin
amazing
holy [ __ ] we arguments were written
specifically by me during our
deliberations that this is one of the
best games ever made I thought I if you
gave me like an hour I could get draw up
an argument for why it's the best game
ever made but that's beside the point
and not the point it's the best game of
2017 as almost universally agreed upon
at GameSpot there were arguments but we
snuff them out pretty readily the game
itself snuff them out right away even in
April like it like thinking about the
beginning of the year like the amount of
time I spend in this game it was almost
immediately apparent like this is the
game to beat like horizon sorry horizon
zero dawn is like a lot of like a lot of
our like viewers were saying that's
their number one game of the year it's
because of Zelda that I didn't like her
as as much as I might have that just
because a Zelda came along and I think
horizon perfected the open-world nature
of so many games with the last like 10
years that we've been leading up to but
then Zelda said screw that let's just
make the best open-world game ever and
like you won't even see it coming it's
like a lot of people's complaint against
Delta of the few that I've heard is you
know it's not as Elda game there's not
it's not the structured like a Zelda
game like you're losing a lot of the
tenets of Zelda but P does that even
matter here I don't think it matters I
think you know like you should you
should take don't judge a book by its
cover
right is the old saying and that's
especially true in this case because yes
this has zelda in the title and you see
familiar characters and certain elements
peppered in to this game but those are
the the least important aspect of what
nintendo is trying to do and what you
know people like us are getting out of
breath of the wild like i think this
game would be just as strong without
those characters without that title even
without the dungeons get rid of all that
stuff ignore it if you can and
appreciate you can you can no I know but
I mean like as a person like if you can
put those aside as a person we play in
this game you will i think realize about
the true strengths are and that is
everything that is new for zelda in this
game it's just
it's it's incredible the way that that
they build up a world around you by as I
put it you know am i right up is that
you know the laws of nature sort of
dominate everything in this game and it
sort of goes beyond our traditional
understanding of how games work where
you know you sort of understand how
maybe two things interact with one
another and those are those are very
fixed and you sort of master those and
you learn those relationships but here
it's it's almost impossible to master
everything that that is in here months
later we are still figuring out what is
capable or what we're capable of in this
event
unreal game on all counts and I would
like to pass this over to two guests we
have to accept
GameSpot's official game of the Year
award so here you go hi what kind of
whistles all right a lot one Tony oh no
Joe saying tow booking table - oh hey
stuff me today at the Capitol there
Scotia who I'm not on this toxin know me
as Arnie wantoniy Thomas kya Sunday it's
a rocket at the katoki detail wantoniy
Murray school so stay unchanged Amos I
know what a traditional day when is that
smoke you know
Coco Co Cairo tiene la cara mia' I know
you can still attend a skittle an
effusive our show has made us to do a
know stuff that you his name and koona
Derrida all motto Oh doc you mnemonic I
take code nine second birthday uh no me
neither no droid accreta
yoni a no so immoral dictate yoga
mantras gamespot or no gamers Ariana
Grande turkey ariados - one Tony
toxin no you Jonathan I found it a race
communist Arya - hey stop
porygon remove the snare I'm a minute on
your door D de rigueur una moto
Matano unique on there those could take
home a snow day c'mon emo ghost a girl
aside
thank you again based on those lower
thirds that was director he tomorrow
fujibayashi of breath awile and
legendary producer Eiji Aonuma who's
been around since ocarina of time he was
working for a Nintendo few games before
that but I would say that was probably
his breakout hit we were fortunate
enough to go to
to the game Awards they were there in
town for a few different things they're
also showing off valid champions ballot
DLC the second DLC for the game if you
got the chance to play that so I got to
try out the master cycle zero the day
after they announced at the game Awards
after knew his son was on stage whirling
the Masters champion tunic which was
awesome he's always on board for the
cheesy awesome stuff like that yeah and
that was my first time ever meeting
either of them but especially like as
someone who grew up on Zelda first time
meeting o pneuma it was [ __ ] awesome
yeah cool as hell I mean you told me all
the time you meant have a bunch of time
you're like no no approachable gap just
a couple but yeah yeah he is very
approachable yeah but you know this
can't really understand who you be ah
she's relationship to Zelda as well
because he's been around since the Game
Boy Color days when he was at Capcom
Oracle of Ages and Oracle of Seasons and
those games were a little bit different
you know in terms of maybe not the same
way the Philips CDI games were but the
Philips CDI games do what you say they
don't yeah okay anyways okay so like
this is the first time Benes all the
game has won Game of the Year for us we
gave it to a link between worlds a
couple of years ago but I feel like this
is such a different experience it really
is yeah I mean you could look at link
between worlds and say what they did
differently because it's sort of it took
away the the structure of the game and
gave you control over the structure you
know how you went through that adventure
this just it throws so many things out
the windows so many things like and you
can even argue like link between worlds
fetishize did the idea of owning as
owning equipment and having that be the
thing that that propels you through
these games where is in this game yeah
and dungeons or doing things that you're
in order sure yeah
but breath of the wild is sort of just
like oh you think that piece of
equipment is special well we're just
gonna break it which people did have
problems with but I stand
concretely by the fact that that is
integral to the experience the reason
that I'm still yeah one of the reasons
I'm still going back I'm nowhere near as
far as you and we'll talk about that in
a second we'll have an intervention but
I played probably 200 hours I think
maybe a little less maybe give or take a
dozen but breaking weapons it doesn't
matter cuz you're gonna find something
else that's gonna you're gonna it's
gonna satisfy some yeah I mean you don't
even need to find another weapon it's
not about necessarily
don't worry I'll get another weapon it's
okay I can do this without that weapon I
don't need that to win right I mean and
that is such an eye-opening experience
and it teaches you that like again going
back to the idea that this world being
is something bigger than we can really
comprehend and understand part of that
adventure is learning what you're
capable of you know within the context
of this natural world just going back to
like exploration in this game
what's so endearing even just that
acceptance speech is sensing like the
having the courage just shift directions
so heavily yeah and that's what stands
out to me with this game is I will never
look at an open-world game I mean at
games in general but definitely
open-world games as far as when you
consider when you consider looking at an
open-world oh this is making wrecks but
when you consider a map right and and a
map is being laid out and you know just
so many open worlds in the passwords
just like here are all these objectives
that's just literally wiped clean and
you are making your own objectives and
that's based on like the flip which is
your you're on a peak you're on a lot of
this game is just getting height so you
can just survey the land and from
practically every direction there is a
site and so you pinpoint your own
objectives that is so natural and just
brings so much feel of like an actual
Explorer and that's what has kept me
going for so long and I'm still playing
the game and I'm still finding not just
like new lines of sights of like an area
but like straight-up just new areas like
I've not seen before
and then you get sidetracked as and then
yeah twelve hours go by they were like
you were you must have been 80 hours and
at the point where I texted you I was
like I just found this beach town Laurel
and village what's up with that you're
like what he talked about a good one
dude yeah for doing so much I mean I
remember I was jumping off a the thought
process you go through you're like all
right my shrine sensor is going off
mashiki slaves tell me there's a shrine
in this direction based on I'm walking
in it's beeping loudly vibrating I'm
gonna go find it but then it starts I'm
climbing up a cliff and I'm all stop Oh
collect a few mushrooms along the way
the the ones that help you climb faster
I think or whatever they're the ones
that make you see colors that aren't
there yeah
psychedelic properties of breath of the
wild plants we can't talk about it and
that all starts raining like [ __ ] now I
can't climb this cliff you start
slipping down but then you fall and you
start gliding and then all of a sudden
like the storm starts ticking and
there's lightning I'm like I might get
struck by lightning almost sudden it
clears and I'm over this beach villages
I had no idea existed I fell into it the
music changed to like this Beach kind of
a like steel drum soundtrack yeah and
then I found another quest from this
person and then I was like oh wait I'm
kind of distracted cuz I just I think I
see a core exceed over there not even
leaving aside the caloric mass which
tell you is just so many things that
like distract you it's it's very
romantic game yeah like the soundtrack
just randomly like pianos will start
thinking thank you I don't know where
Yankee we're talking about the real term
for that but you'll go into the woods
and there won't be any music it'll be
just kind of ambient like boom boom but
then on some of me Jimmy I like what
it's like these intimate little moment
with a soundtrack obviously there are
there's like Tarrytown
there's any time you're going on city
Zorro's domain Rio village just Gerudo
town it's like all these actual
soundtracks but I was constantly talk
about how this games like in immersive
semi you don't like Zelda games it isn't
a Mersenne you mentioned like the way
that the system's overlap it's still
astounding to find new things you can do
like you see here in the b-roll we're
using Magni sious to lift this block
into the minecart so then you can then
you use that you stand on the block and
you can't you can't make nice things
you're standing on so by putting the
block between you and the minecart you
can make Nice's the minecart and start
flying and this is the longevity that
they literally owned up to like this is
ridiculous right here but this is also
you know maybe a couple months in I
think Peter you said one of the
developers like hinted at doing this
remember that you like did an interview
and he's like yeah you can do some like
this and then sure enough like a week
later someone figured out to do it and
that doesn't build that in like that
they were talking about how when they
were doing testing someone put this
together like oh wow though we didn't
know you could do that but we left it
it's like it's not a bug it's just
interesting things that people it's
fascinating
yeah I guess worse if Sims go it's it's
I mean I you you really do fall back
into like a breathing world like always
where like the Twitter videos that like
have always surface throughout the year
like two weeks ago so we saw something
yes I'm new but like also someone just
like pointing out like hey did you
notice that like wind in the in the game
not only like corresponds with like
moving actual like grass and trees but
you look at the sky it's like the clouds
are moving the same direction
everything is so symbiotic and in
natural and it's - what's immersive and
it's the audio it's the light chime it's
not like a you know an overbearing
classic tunes with like the overworld
it's just a hint of a piano and it's
just enough to like drive emotion yeah
it highlights the emotions you're having
rather than trying to force them upon
you yeah and like honestly like you talk
about like it is the purest adventure
game of ever play like I first let him
tell like came out before I was around
but like everybody talks about it as one
of the most important games in their
life in the sense that it actually kind
of showed them what video games would be
capable of in terms of showing you an
invention or this open-world this game
almost the way I look at it maybe it's a
weird comparison but I consider this
game like the original Legend of Zelda
of my life at least it reminds me it
shows me what like an adventure and a
game can mean because like your snow
bring down a cliff and all of a sudden
you see a core exceed you stop off but
it doesn't matter like you could pick up
a spot the distance I'm gonna climb up
there and there's no like I love Ubisoft
games but there's no map marker telling
you no exclamation point like an MMO
there's nothing telling you there might
be something interesting over there
you're like creating your own story out
of it and that's just so ridiculous I
know Justin you were talking about that
aspect of like the actual like you kind
of find your own stories in this game
more than the main narrative I mean that
for me that was the thing that that I
think really cemented this in my memory
like one of the first things that I did
in the game was like I have four hearts
I've gone off the cliff and I just start
exploring and like I find out I'm just
following this path I see a Lionel and
it's like whoa he's so strong but I run
past him and then I'm I'm climbing up
this snow-covered Mountain and my health
is dropping like I'm suddenly in a
situation that I've never been in before
I have an inventory just full of apples
like my health is going down because
it's too cold and like if I get to the
top of this there's got to be a town
there's gotta be something that's gonna
save me and so I'm just I'm just
throwing apples in my Elk running past
every enemy like a wolf
Oh God during the interview on Numa we
were saying he was saying that was the
initial concept they had for the game
was like we want to make a game where
you would want to go climb a mountain
but first you would have to forage and
scavenge and get the necessary supplies
to get you up the mountain and then and
then there like that naturally leads to
what are you gonna do when you get to
the top of the mountain they're like
well you'll be able to see more and
they're like what leads from there and
then they're like well we need a way for
you to be able to get down without
climbing back down and then that's what
the collider comes in and then they're
like well if you see something in the
distance how does that work they're like
well what if we add endurance to it
because you're gonna like run out of
energy holding that and then you get to
a another hill over the real-world
example and explain why I'm on my phone
is my blood sugar is actually kind of
low right now but like in the real world
no it's I need showed us someone's
getting from you but like Zelda will
prepare you like you need to build up
your stamina to get things taken care of
so maybe you need to take a potion that
will boost that up right mm-hmm
like there's all there's all these sort
of things that but you can still fight a
rent as it's like there there is a
solution maybe you can get that piece of
armor maybe maybe you can find a potion
that's gonna help you survive but you
can also just fight through it like like
I said at the beginning of the game like
my health is going down that should have
been a warning not to do this but I
could still make it like I had enough
inventory that I made it to the end and
it was you get to the top of the
mountain you're like well everything is
still kind of messed up up here I'm
gonna glide down go back to somewhere
safe and then you watch a guy complete
the entire game in about 30 minutes
straight out of the shrine of
Resurrection just booking it like it's
in like my personal time I get about
I've never I've never seen a game last
for so long and just discovery that's
endless even without the DLC even
without like yeah like five hundred yeah
I mean if I mean exceed or something I
mean like a good hundred was like doing
montages and like time lapses works work
it wasn't slow last week but like toward
the end of one day it was a we were
really busy and then we're like oh now
we got a we're prepping we're prepping
for the streams next week what can I do
right now and Robley I should probably
play Zelda it's pretty good but the very
fact that like I don't know the idea of
the shrines themselves like probably the
biggest structural departure you
mentioned my
beating the game in half-an-hour like
you can they say go go try to beat Ganon
at Hyrule Castle of course you're gonna
run into a Guardian first 12 guardians
and you're probably to die is because
you're not gonna have ancient arrows
you're not gonna have anything solid you
can fight a guard yeah and you can go
fly can be you probably want to the
whole story revolves around you
preparing for the fight and it's been a
hundred years so it's not like you feel
weird that you're taking so long to
prepare for it's like it's already been
a century there's not any immediate rush
they want me to get there like they're
like take your time and build yourself
up and then we'll kill Ganon for another
hundred years hopefully but don't make
it a selfish journey just great just
enjoy the world if you really want to
yeah do you look at someone like like
The Witcher it's no different than that
right like I gotta save my daughter ciri
and it's like first skill ago let's get
wasted
okay what's new a bard but the shrines
themselves obviously it ditches the
whole like eight or nine dungeon
structure of a Zelda game for these
smaller bite-sized shrines of which
there are 120 well minus the dlc dlc is
130 something's right and those
obviously like you build your hearts up
and your endurance your stamina by
getting the orbs from the shrines from
the monks and the shrines of the like
the sheikah ancient monks and you offer
those to the goddess hylia and she gives
you hearts or endurance but the shrines
themselves are like smaller puzzles that
might have been like pulled from what in
other games might have been a larger
dungeon is sure and it but they feel so
otherworldly yeah hurts the world around
you that you find yourself in them and
what's interesting is that like I may be
trying to describe to rollick never that
shrine where you know you had to do this
and it's like no I don't know you're
talking about like no come on remember
you had to do this to beat it and then
you maybe I show you the chart you're
like oh I remember it as a shrine ride
to do this yeah right it's not even so
much about the puzzles necessarily it's
about what it compels you to do the
physics and and the runes right your
abilities to manipulate objects and all
that stuff it's so well thought out and
orchestrated in the sense that yeah like
you come across these shrines that you
know there are a few of them where you
can just stand there I was talking to
someone about it the other day
granted it was in the DLC but like a lot
of the other shrines had the same thing
where you you sometimes they're so
difficult you just kind of look at them
in a very enjoyable way and just think
you think about how you're gonna do it
because you can see a multitude of
different ways of tackling it using you
know cry osis or you know magnesia swear
ever it is like you just can look and
you can like feasibly see different
layouts and waypoints and then you
tackle it and it's like it's in your
review you said like it's a wonderful
break from the actual game it's just
like do these shrines and just kind of
have like a moment to just like work
your brain in a different way and some
of the shrines aren't even like meant to
be difficult they're just meant to be
these like bookends to this mini
adventure you just add like I finally
just the shrine quests we're in gowron's
right outside of go-around city you're
supposed to bring that like rock cake to
the one who's like who glossed energy
tunneling in and you finally bring it to
him he tells you in it's called the
trends called hail of greed or greedy
hill I know a steep incline and you're
sprinting up dodging rocks on the way up
to the orb it's not hard at all but it
they call it greedy hill because if you
want to risk getting rupees there's like
blue rupees scattered throughout it so
you can go out of the way to maybe get
run over by a rock but you'll get like
an extra 150 rupees out of it like I
love how they're like those in core ox
seeds are such little like great
bookends to these this mini story you
just had and I love that idea like well
I think the core exceeds obviously
there's 900 something yeah yeah yeah and
like I finally got the core rock mass
for the DLC I finally start playing the
DLC recently after like again like I
think about 200 hours or something now
but the quote now the core arc mast like
the game to me has become finding core
exceeds but that doesn't stop me from
finding this random shrine I never had
or coming across this I told you I had
that quest the lovers pond or whatever
there was a Gerudo woman on one side and
the Hylian guy on the other and you had
to essentially like vicariously help
them both yeah yeah and and then it's
funny because it's it's the games really
funny and a lot is this aspect the guy
like he's like here for your time it's a
red ruby 20 rupees and they're like in
my head I'm like what the [ __ ] that's
all he's giving me to do and then the
garuda woman she's like that's all
you're giving him first time and then
she makes you him give you like another
100 or something it's fantastic like the
writing in that way but then of course
you have the divine beast which kind of
become you don't have to do them they
can make the final fight harder or easy
and they give you those four powers you
get from the champions they're kind of
like the sages if you play older I mean
all the games so those well I guess the
powers they give you plus the runes that
you know the rune powers you have those
are the only things that separate you in
terms of ability
from the enemies that are in the world
yeah I guess maybe they can't tell like
range combat I guess they can't take
like super-powered like meals and stuff
to power up
yeah they don't he'll do that in master
mode it messed me a maximun to do yeah
so but but it's interesting how you can
choose to not take an advantage to keep
yourself on even footing with you turn
them off for a while because for sure I
turn them all off like I like for
volleys gala remotely scales the only
one maybe I'll leave on but just in here
I mean yeah you're right like and thank
God you can turn those off because it's
like two rooks protection every time you
like
pull out your shield or a giant bubble
around you it's which looks cool but it
was but a minute and then it's just
distracting because it for me it breaks
that immersive yeah I you know and
that's such a departure to write like
they have that they have such a balance
with like the art style and just pure
realism right like they could have gone
in any direction but it's like that
happy medium as far as style and like
yeah just pure realism that's funny like
people knock this game for not being
Zelda enough I would only knock it for
being Zelda at all yeah like the really
the only big problem I had with the game
is is the narrative like even if they if
this wasn't linked if this was just a
random character who woke up in this
weird kind of mechs medieval and
scientific future e-world like that
would have by itself been fascinating
like I think the the Zelda hook pulled
in people who might not have been
immediately interested but the narrative
was kind of the weakest aspect well also
like this other name allowed Nintendo to
devote their biggest team to it so it's
a Zelda game so we can spend all of me
yeah well and that's how they operate
right yeah and that's the reason we
don't see a lot of new IPs from them all
the time necessarily is because they
understand that people are more well
to try out new things if there's at
least something to bring them along but
like fujibayashi sauna now new Masson
said in the acceptance speech like
that's what makes this all the more
impressive to me is that they had Zelda
and they decided to say screw it we're
gonna do something crazy there we have
an interview I did with them that's
going up today I think and they were
saying like they were pretty scared the
entire time it sure like much of it like
I was saying that he he didn't he played
a lot of Skyrim and he didn't really
look at it for design aspects but he
looked at it and looked at the Bethesda
team to say what do we need to do to
prepare for design and development
eventualities with the wild because it
was it was their biggest team Nintendo
has ever assembled a lot of veterans it
was something wholly new with one of the
most iconic Series in games and that
makes it even more impressing me like
how bold and kind of downright crazy
that was it's it's really it gets I mean
I think all of us have some love for a
Nintendo that goes back a long time
right and it's it's safe to say there's
been a point in recent years where I
think a lot of people were questioning
like is antennas are really relevant
like they will put out a good game now
and then a great game but are they still
an industry leader in some regard it
kind of warms my heart to see that
they're back but more what it does is it
makes me excited to think I can still
look at a look at at this one company as
you were going to surprise me into like
me for years to come and I'm really
happy that I can say that because there
aren't many publishers and developers
that really do give you that like
endless confidence in them and I feel
like this has given me that again for
Nintendo I mean like when I played
horizon earlier in the year I was like
okay cool Sony's still Sony is
publishing new stuff and like I'm
getting we're getting exclusives on the
ps4 that is new and like guerrilla games
just did a 180 and like knocked out of
the park and then you know say what you
will about Microsoft they had like spike
up hacking about there's still like
unique things to it but of course
throughout the year the switch was just
just this awesome comeback and like I I
didn't it wasn't that I didn't care
about intended during the Wii U years
but I really did not go out of my way to
play much Nintendo the hardware side
right I know like I would love to see
Mario maker and smash come to the switch
now that I can relive those experiences
because I mean I played them but I
didn't really like dive into them Wii U
but to see Nintendo finally figured out
not just in the marketing and in the
hardware and especially in the software
like them even like
we talked about how long we wanted a 2d
Metroid to come back this is kind of a
tangent but they were confident off to
hand it off the mercury steam I know
they had some oversight and we have
development members but still like
here's here's something people been
asking for for a while you guys make
this well we will oversee it and it came
out
Sherman talked about more I think you we
talked about it a lot personally but
sure fantastic game but like Nintendo
itself outside of Zelda is just like
returned full force and in my opinion
was like it was my favorite platform to
play on this year I mean really by
siphon like PC or anything but like the
switch Zelda you could not have asked
for a better game ever to just say hey
what's up guys we're back and we're
gonna kick your face in with this game
oh yeah yeah I mean it breath of the
wild will be a footnote on the timeline
and I mean a photo is good enough a
milestone for game design and Nintendo I
mean I think for many of us there is
gaming before and after breath of the
wild just like there you know the few
games we look back on like that yeah
like I always find myself thinking about
like for me at least like ocarina of
time like there's actually that that
callback but it's not like you know
overusing this game but it's not so much
the nostalgia I think about that game
it's me remembering how I felt and then
I think about a kid playing this game
today and that's gonna be then Brett I
know it's like it's like a like a like a
fight I have I'm so envious of just
anyone just I mean it's like you've got
so good they they're gonna look at games
like pass this and be like it's nothing
like Zelda huh I mean it's just the
mystery and the play style that you're
just given like however you want to do
it like you know they they so
brilliantly incorporated things like
like Minecraft right as far as like
crafting food it's not just like you
know craft some Doritos it's like kind
of neat to think about like the food
you're making I don't know okay
part of me thinks like well maybe some
kids like well I want an indirect carrot
here's just a carrot he's a missile do
maybe that happens I don't know I just
know you're gonna be a good dad
thanks yeah okay this is a charming it
just it just like what's a survival game
to it
Mergent mr. survival games adventure
game open world game it is a Selda game
like when you get down to it but like
not like in the sense that a lot of
people might define it as but it still
captured the idea of an adventure a hero
coming back up to like reclaim the world
and everything along with the specific
characters link Zelda can and take
characters different time in a different
way that they've approached it but it's
still just like but by real and it's
like by taking that risk as far as you
know you have to get through the
tutorial if you will off of getting all
your rooms right getting the hang glider
from then on anyone can pick that up at
any age and have fun with it mm-hmm like
it's endless that's what's so neat to me
like you hear about like I know what
outlet did a coverage of it has been
over at Pollak yeah he like gave his son
as you know the game and his son for
like a whole week would like take it for
like a few hours a day and just go in a
corner and just get like lost and then
like he's I think he said like a week
later yes I'm like we're so what's going
on where are you he's like hey have you
done this yet that's like it yeah I did
that like within the first hour okay and
you haven't gotten the glider yeah I
don't think he he had basically his son
just had was finding enjoyment and just
like roaming free right like on the gray
plateau specifically he had left it yet
right yeah and he was having a blast
with it and that's like it's the kind of
the the quasi tutorial of the game right
yeah oh man we could probably read about
this game but that is our game of the
year of 2017 OOP yeah we're finally done
if you're watching this live stick
around we are gonna be playing it Rob's
gonna pick up controller momentarily but
I just want to say thank you so much
this was a different format we try to
change up Game of the Year formats every
year this year the best of 2017 we've
been calling it was a top 10 games of
all years to decide to just go with 10
games which which helped the argument
but also made it very tough because if
you got into the top 10 that means a
fantastic game there were a bunch that
you just barely didn't make it but we
also have these editor spotlight videos
where a bunch of the content team
champion their favorite game that wasn't
in the top 10 so go check those out go
check out 10 through 1 or 10 through 2
so to speak they started off near
automata and then we did what remains to
be a Finch hell-blade Senna was
sacrifice Wolfenstein to the new
Colossus horizon zero dawn divinity
original sin to resonable 7 super mario
odyssey persona 5 and now Zelda
we're getting really good done I've done
that like what seven times now at this
point eight times but uh yeah it's been
really fun thank you so much for joining
with our holiday theme you we never
really mentioned it obviously but like
we've been doing the ugly sweater
holiday theme for a while and you
probably figured it out Rob's our
naughty list up there next to raw behind
there you got you can see so now it's
three reindeers hugging speaking of
children talking about Zelda that's a
great sweater to be wearing but anyway
thank you guys so much for joining up
with all that stuff on YouTube or
GameSpot if you hear live I don't know I
guess we don't need a spoiler warning
for Zelda right like we're not gonna see
anything
spoiler ish we're just gonna play Zelda
we're gonna show you a bunch of game
play until take um xining kicks us out
or until GS universe needs a studio so
yeah let's get into it
okie dokie our children you're playing
we're in it to win it
oh [ __ ] is a very early save yeah early
save I thought you meant relatively for
you like 300 hours in now I initially
last night I was telling you're like oh
let's do you know what no be a great
thing to do is do the Tarrytown quest
and then I and then I might not Eve as
self we've realized the amount of rupees
and wood and Oh where's my fast travel I
want to get from here to here good luck
pal that's another you don't even have
enough weapons to cut down trees enough
for the wood whatever you can find about
us had a whole series of speedruns where
you would try to go from the beginning
and beat the game not necessarily
necessarily speedruns but Peter and I
would take turns blindfolding one
another and directing the person
blindfolded it is kinky and also was a
headache and I think we got burnout so
explain to people watching you might not
be familiar the game what you're trying
to do because if I know you're trying to
market that horse right now this is a
part in the game we're at Apple Inc has
our insanely bad cramp and you have to
try to get a horse to have
kick you in the back and fell down well
her eyes go crossed I do I go back
I'm Tigers I'll try try get on this
horse can you do with just that armor
would you might be achieving know that
don't you mean to need more endurance
you probably haven't liked nothing right
well the endurance yeah but he's
probably hearing you they're also making
a lot of noise yeah well when you hop
yeah yeah really when you're hop I
thought I was like dude I am on to you I
see you dude did you guys all learn that
shield surf when you were walking around
that that means like as I feel like
that's something you might learn a
different time they never told me until
I was up in the Hebrew Mountains gotcha
oh oh yeah they told me when I was up in
the Hebrew reading cuz I can't I heard
about it from people in the office but I
first time I saw it was when you're just
walking around that the grasslands and
there were some kids shield surfing down
a hill yeah this is how I do what yeah
there's that there's like two guys or a
night kid like there are two kind
surfing and you walk up to them and like
hey well if you do this if you can do
this faster than we're doing it we'll
pay you some money yeah that's like oh
so this is how we do that first person I
saw mention it was the girl the
different
she's like the absol did you guys run
into the girl in the Heber region in the
cabin who was the ex-professional oh
yeah the first time I heard someone's
gonna civically mention it yeah sure
like yeah it's a Time Trial the type
thing yeah yeah yeah Justin I never
heard of that that's insane yeah when
you're just walking on the main area
there's some guys who are hanging out by
a tree and I see you're trying the
distance this is the best get that's
right okay oh so the other thing that's
missing from this game the thing that
like you have to get unlock all the
towers first like I don't so long ago
that almost dropped it down for me you
can't pet dogs you stand near a dog and
home yeah that's come up why the hell
can't you pet a dog so let's see the I
on a serious note the one thing that I
would love to see I'm serious I know
irrelevant
I kind of missed the idea of the the
Triforce being a thing like a physical
object that you have to attain in a way
even a winwaker yeah no I just I would
love like a world like this where there
there is like these like very powerful
super crazy relics like very yeah really
freaking deep in the world like like I
don't know maybe it's just I want more
of this game and that's the immediate
thing I can like insert into that but
whatever it was dreaming I like to think
of the those shriveled up monks and
shrines there's a deeper story to all
that those guys mmm
they're sheikah right I don't think
they're sheikah I think sheikah you can
always tell because it's it's the no
wait you're right there she go I'm
thinking of you go clan you clan is the
Sheik assigned upside down yeah which is
kind of like yet turning a crucify down
oh did I do the wrong one
what there's some information that I'd
like to insert into this conversation
but it would potentially be a spoiler
yeah would be we can we've been doing
spoilers on the street for the champions
ballad yeah that just came never mind
not champions ballad so one of the other
things that early on let me know that
this was a really special experience is
like as I get older I don't play games
as much as I used to like a gamer I play
a lot I play a wider variety of games I
don't beat as many games as I used to
when I was younger and this was one of
the first games in a long time where I
would be playing until 3 or 4 a.m. yeah
it was also tough this year to be games
with all the good games coming out and
they're sold are so many huge like long
experiences and I've spent over a
hundred hours in a lot of other games
but this is like oh like almost 200
hours yeah it's so like it's hard to
when you have to play so many games when
you have to know so much about a wide
variety of games it's hard to die to
give so much time into a single title
this made me happy to do that also just
emphasize how awesome the switch can be
in terms of portability and you just sit
on the couch time
gets away from you I think of link
handing these guts over in your hand
just oh yeah yeah I finally upgraded my
Hylian tunic all the way and you needed
a lot of bow cobbling guts and amber
like you do the that I started upgrading
our murse in the most difficult things
of finding words are like you know we
need a star fragment for each one of
these oh yeah Lionel's sometimes karyam
or you could just see the oh yeah like
one of them we have one ways to get a
star fragment is literally waiting for a
shooting star also like one of the most
difficult fights in the game for me up
until the point I did it was the Lionel
in the Coliseum this I I finally I used
like six weapons on him I finally you
know I was mounting him I was shooting
in the face I was space to sing him
stuff to stop him and shoot in the face
some time I used I used our BOCES fury
that was felt on him finally killed him
and then I was like oh there's it was
now that I had the DLC there was a the
phantom helmet was right nearby and I
went to go grab it and all of a sudden
blood came up yeah and he was right
there behind me Gibbler damn it the
first time swords about this game is
like it's it's corny to say but I like
it feels like magic when like things
happen like the first time a Blood Moon
happened I like yeah you got scared what
do i do what do I go with the star
fragments the first time I saw star
fighting would fall from the sky yeah
like I was playing that me Mormon game
before anybody knew what was going on
and then just like I don't know who to
talk to you like robbed you ever see a
falling star and lay you're like what
yeah like dude and if you don't get to
them soon enough don't they disappear if
you don't they disappear very like a
glow come oh they do disappear yeah so
if you don't get to it by morning okay
we have all night they're still they're
still so hard to find sometimes it was
very very very good tweet Rob that I
don't think I ever complimented you on
when the master cycle shown off you're
like you were you were pretending to be
late or the stable keep you're like hey
would you like to register your what the
hell what the is that we see I probably
use horses for a total of
45 minutes in my hundred eighty some
horses are legit you can feed it they
are you can do this you do dressage did
you the quest where there's a horse show
you got a Gundam style ha the horse
there is hope there isn't a quest like
that I mean yeah there's horse racing
there is one of those that I raised a
horse racing one yeah oh I hated that
that was hard because if the horse is
like horse does not want to do what you
tell it to do yeah I love um I fear
these people you'd like run into like
getting quests out of like NPC's in the
world is so fun because they don't they
don't like just like the nature of this
game they don't like put a objective on
your map right they say oh go to like
the waterfall in between two peaks or
something like that in this region and
you legit like follow signs in the road
and like gauge what the hell they were
talking about there's those two Brunt
like the twins I think in the dueling
Peaks I'm just I have no idea I just
said this person but yeah it's just fun
to like you know again like ho never
known this trend Oh shrine
yeah again let this lick this game just
does not like heavy hand the map at all
like the map is yours chill out oh ah
the old WAGO kata shrine remember this
one I do
skip what's your favorite shrine and the
name of it go mmm one greedy hill
margosa nah it's not the name of a
shrine I didn't trying that it's called
greedy hill nope
no way absolutely not it's called greedy
hill Oh No so here's okay sorry if you
translate that's what he says wouldn't
get down here like right here sure yeah
I was like why is you so like oh I
remember this one I actually do this is
yeah you got
we're using like Magne says creatively
in this too
I don't know there's do this yeah yeah
you know I remember there was a few
early on that sounded like anagrams or
ambigrams ambigrams of like owl Numa and
yada and stuff and I had a theory that
they were yeah good job good to have fun
here we love this game whoops what names
tweeted something before it was done I'm
dumb doing about that game here
cool see this this is a great shrine
what we do here is we put these boxes
and one and oh I done gave a game of the
year - oh yeah copycats yeah we did it
first
oh you heard it here first oh so we saw
like the big game award show down in LA
where we we got to talk with alan luma
and fujibayashi like i think it's gonna
be rare outside of like PC at like a PC
focus site to not give zolda game of the
PC gamer gave divinity original sin to
but I think it would've been funnier if
you see game board games all the gear
like could we love divinity - but we've
all spent a long time playing Zelda
that's the modding community for switch
one thing I hope is a result of all this
is that intend ode like spins things up
to get us a new game not like right away
but not years and years after the fact
Joris mass came out very shortly after
ocarina time and that was so just a
different experience using that same
engine yeah I would love to explore
something new in this I mean I still I
still think they're going to add more
DLC for this game next year but we just
don't know it there they announced it
during a direct that sound mean maybe
don't not excellent platform and and
they could easily like justify
teleporting you to a new location or
something or a shrine that you go into
this bigger than you know just any other
shrine like but that is big you know
it's like the the master trial stuff
like that that was substantial but even
with Mario Kart 8 Mario credit II was
super popular
that would have been awesome yeah but
for mariokart like the laid out here's
the year of DLC that you're gonna get
and even as popular as it was we didn't
get more out of it I kind of think that
they might do a new title like Legend of
Zelda something else
sure like perhaps four switches over
yeah well I mean like you even and maybe
the next year or two you can find these
right so stack three and then make it a
bridge from the top of the three boxes
yeah okay yeah you're just making this
more complicated prove it you can climb
these right yes yeah he knows that for
the comedy at this point that's too
close I think but that right moving on
yeah no no no no yeah yeah right the
right side of the plank like right in
the middle of top box and yeah oh that's
gotta be like right here right I don't
even know if you're lined up on the
z-axis well yeah look oh yeah yeah good
feeling about this nailed it
wish I had my camera I would totally
take a selfie oh no you're gonna fall so
great game if they did do another round
of DLC or if they if they use this
engine to do something similar what
would you want out of it would you just
would you be happy with just more of
this yeah I mean like I think there's so
on the one hand like I'd like the the
DLC that we've gotten like it at least
the first batch right like it was just
sort of like these very like bite-sized
encapsulated challenges that were
distinct from the world like separate in
a way I want something more that's like
set within the world so like the
champions ballad got close but it still
felt like I was taking part in the same
locations I want to somehow be removed
from the map we know and have it extend
in a certain direction like we know if
you go to the West right you can like
climb up a wall where it literally stops
you and it's like yeah first time I ever
ran into the right so so we know that
there's more out there like even the map
shows features on a piece of the map
that you can't get to so it stands to
reason that there's more
stuff there so I would like them to
extend the map further how that ties
into the story I don't know whether
that's important or not I also don't new
biome could they do that they haven't
like a new dog fit everything okay link
coming to like an urban ass city it's
like get out of your kid like holy [ __ ]
what if what if it been just linked to
the past did you and they put another
dark world map on top of this right I
mean but isn't that all saying I would
not like that I wouldn't know yeah
oh your father 120 shrines like Carter
but upside down yeah simply it makes
your brain really work I love it or like
you go to a point the Twilight Realm
are you have kind of a space-themed like
the this is obviously a civilization or
it seems like a civilization that could
have traveled into space like what if
you went to the moon or something cool
another planet I'd be on board this is I
was talking about how this setting is
actually not all that different from I
mean it's different but it's not all
that different from horizon it's a post
post apocalypse right like it's still
you find all this ancient technology
they're trying to figure out in this
wilderness that has overtaken the world
after this calamity happened in this
game or the robot taking over and
horizon zero dawn mm-hmm there's
something so grim - about like the
memories of like how you know like in
between the castle like do you know
there's a town around hyrule castle like
but that was a town and it's leveled
like when those guardians like they show
it I like really quickly those those
things like you know getting controlled
again and like spilling out like that's
so great just like these things just
killing I love that you can go past and
ranch oh yeah
so I remember the when they first showed
gameplay of the game they're like look
so you can sneak up on a boat Collin
camp and steal their weapons while
they're sleeping so they get up and run
the log and they're not there anymore I
thought like that I was like that alone
is awesome like that yeah and that was
just what not even the tip of the
iceberg when it came to the
possibilities in this game this is a
Metal Gear
wait he doesn't see you when you do that
he's confused
moving typical here's a book hobbling I
mean yeah they are there lower IQ put a
mean horn the slower Inka quotient no
not Inka yeah turn-turn whatever you
prefer
who's the input god damn it
a shadow temple from Ocarina used to be
my favorite time Julian went back with a
brain and played a bow
sorry nice people like knock the combat
in this game is it's not all I agree the
thing is is that like early on you don't
need to understand everything about
combat but especially if you play a
master mode yeah oh god you need to be
you need to understand every single
parry dodge like that's possible like
you need to be so on top of everything
and then you end then once you guys
thrown rocks you put into that you
realize like what really is capable in
this world and how comment is pretty
cool it's not as simple as it seems at
first glance I still have not gone this
year shield parry four Guardians
oh I've gotten the Guardian on that I
don't use it with anybody else in master
mode I swear to God there is no Tommy
how did that guy just depends of a
distance from them the laser still
travels like it is you're close enough
to them it's like right when it makes
the ping and then I do it but what I'm
saying is like it's not even predictable
like there is no like set time as far as
the beat because I remember Jake was
like oh whatever it beeps Matt so at
this moment no but in like bill this
fire like maybe a half second early or
late I saw I got it yeah you just gotta
know like and lately when the laser is
certain distance really then you start
swinging you swing too late obviously
it's gonna smoke you you guys ever do
the side quests in a concrete go village
with the whoa you did it I nailed it I
used to call karaoke village and then
you called Rito village do rio village
with the fireflies which one and
Kakariko village Cole I think fire I
didn't wrote music there's a
there's a woman who like is upset or
like she said she wants oh yeah she
wants like fireflies so you go you know
you pick up like eight and then you like
open it up and her her pad this is
really awesome
that's all that's all I gotta say about
that horse yeah I wish you could have
expanded out your house a little bit
more like it was nice having a having
this space to make your own yeah but
like oh no when you Tarrytown where do
they go cuz you have to bring them to
the wedding and then I can't everybody
how are you just so there they go up to
Tarrytown but then when I'm still trying
to build my house in a hotty know
village I can't find them unless it's
during the wrong time of day no you lost
your chance buddy are you serious I
don't know do that yeah I thought they
stayed there right outside your house
they usually do but then you bring off
to the wedding right Terry time they
appreciate for one that help bill
Carlson or Hudson but I love that after
a while I figured I find a flame sword
and I hit meat on the ground before I
picked up their just cook it immediately
or if you draw if you kill something in
the fire like though if meat drops
anywhere on the ground in the Elden
region the Goron region it just starts
cooking a party and we didn't get an
invite that's an orgy dude that's what's
Gator asses in there literally you know
fire arrows you do where's my where's my
invite oh I'm sorry
of course like [ __ ] jump in the water
like hey what's up mistakes were made I
[Music]
love when they start figuring out what
you do with the bombs and kick it at you
yeah yeah that's pretty awesome or like
when the mob ones will like I know
frustration just pick up a column and
throw it at you the only thing stopping
you from saying this is my favorite game
of all time is I do not want to back
self into that corner I feel the same
way I'm just kidding I'm just I didn't
say that it's close and I feel like
it'll be hard for it not to stand the
test of time but yeah you don't want to
do it in the same year that a kid that
came out but it really feels like that
yeah what else is in your top games of
all time
I mean Majora's Mask I would if anybody
played gun in my head and I told me to
tell them I'd say the drawers master
Majora's Mask timesplitters 2 XCOM 2 red
alert 2 last sequels number two's the
DOS well so when both are the welcome -
I'd say put my blue and red I think time
flutters - is the weird one Zombies Ate
My Neighbors which I played that reason
the games I'm not good let's talk to
this guy good co-op when I was 6 yeah
good rental game what what what's your
favorite game fall fancy tactics yeah
just kidding I played like half an hour
of it yeah I didn't get a chance I know
supposedly deserves what's what's one of
your favorite guys I spent like a whole
weekend getting the towers I just take
them for granted now that's what's a
funny one
I thought about Tarrytown I was like oh
yeah that's doable I know how that
mission goes and it's like yeah no
towers no stamina huh here be a
lumberjack for three days right well -
if you're good yeah ok
what did I go what's in your list of
favorite games of all time yeah gonna
kill this guy Bri go at bring go he was
named oh god I'm Ringo the name of my
horse was brave okay bye see it's our
horse horse and Lord of the Rings Justin
I'm sorry you were fair game
honestly like ocarina is really really
up there I could buy a like I've
replayed that game so many freaking
times why is there a shoe no stole my
show this is free no you guys look at
wearing brand-new socks today I saw to
celebrate game of the year
I'm right about you just over here so
what sucks am i wearing I'm wearing
socks they have they have smores on them
fine as marijuana leaves on mine I just
they were the only ones that were clean
I got them at comic-con last year as MTV
socks with Mary Jane leaves are like
chronic on my sauce have this white
check on it
like breath of the wild is in contention
for one of my the best games of all time
like yeah right now portal is definitely
like that's such a memorable experience
yeah that that portal moment where
you're on the conveyor belt right and
you're like the game just leaves it up
to you like I wonder how many people
like thought that was the end of the
game oh they just kill you in the end do
you guys see the combine bridge
constructor and portal in a game yeah
it's like 10 bucks I just came out like
today you're ready yet yeah
not weird I've heard like okay things
about it like the portal connection
isn't that doesn't like subversive weird
yeah it's like it's really character
with portal aperture technology right
right they do that's a weird is that
weird partnership like valve in them I
wouldn't put anything past valve man
they're the most unpredictable
inconsistent company out there well like
I don't know about inconsistent they're
unpredictable what it's totally
inconsistent dota 2 here sucks
here we've got three episodes a
half-life 2 coming out just kidding
two also in a few years time we're gonna
buy a Warcraft 3 mod and make that the
thing that we do I think that's
unpredictable inconsistent would mean
like the stuff they put out is sometimes
good sometimes bad to me like everything
they put out is good I mean is making
their decision making is inconsistent
like they're gonna dedicate I mean even
they know those business smelting things
and Majora's Mask so Majora's Mask is
also in definitely in my top 5 games of
all time and then they're one of the big
reasons I like that so much is because
it did really weird bold things with a
Zelda formula Rob hey guys so pissed
okay see ya we're going the same way
this is awkward
hey there's a shrine its 10:33 it's good
I was thinking you guys wanted we could
jump to like my we could jump from early
to the latest game with dirtbike do that
freaking do it alright let's do a dirt
bike and then maybe go see another I
don't know he bro region the snow or you
know my favorite region is the Acala
reason I like the autumn vibe it's gotta
be literally the worst yeah right well
you're probably a guru guy are you hell
no dude Ferren oh the swamps down south
yeah like the really good worse is so
good it was there in Hebrew I did not
explore for like my first 50 hours and
I'm like wow there's a whole - whole
nother biomes and Ferren forces like
just heavy rains and lightning like
you're like severely limited as far as
like climbing and even heaven even
talked about that before the game so
only can you cut to a camera real quick
two seconds Danka just load up stardew
valley i was gonna say it's crazy that
we didn't even remember before the game
came out you saw someone based on
because the e3 demo for this game was
play for an hour I remember Dave Jewett
did a catapult thing I mean you went
back for like a second hour but I
remember even in Dave Jewess first hours
he made a catapult that I think the
Nintendo treehouse rap had not seen yeah
with the stasis and the magnificent line
something up in cattle right but Pete
saw like I think it was a reddit thread
where someone's like you we didn't know
if it was fake or not but the other like
supposedly if you're like in a lightning
storm you have metal arm or metal armor
or weapons or stuff you can get it'll
start like warning you and you'll almost
you'll get struck by lightning if you
wait too long we're like no way and then
that happens that's like I'm I often
times keep wooden weapons specifically
for that yeah sure ancient gear as well
it was good pastor Josh Shaw former
GameSpot producer over at twitch now he
did the Gerudo region first most people
do so bad as most people do me for their
good yeah the Zoras domain was where I
am it's it's kanae room I don't know
most people do like that vert that first
and then do that divine beast if you do
the divine beast and then yeah because
you get the extremes in the Gerudo you
need
warm you need to stay warm at night and
to stay cool and during the day
stay cool baby all right thanks recycle
should I give a spoiler warning yes know
what's in the trailer if you haven't
seen the champions ballot trailer and
don't know that the vehicle gadget that
link gets I guess turn this off right
now if you don't pay attention to the
game I love ya
so let me give you a little rundown on
how I like to use the bike first you
want it's a bike you want it equipped
the ancient you want to go with the
ancient era bow and arrow there yeah
okay uh-huh
ancient laid salt uh-huh uh-huh get
ready for you ready for you ready ready
for the big one
look how cool I freakin look oh he used
my uh you let me bow right I need I
really so how do you get that helm again
he just got it from my amiibo this
office has amiibos because I'm one of
those okay look at this what does this
do doesn't give you an ability pin yeah
so she looks sick as flow yeah other
than looking amazing I get all my all my
weapons that are ancient
have higher damage and this head I mean
I would imagine for each region prevents
me from getting cold in areas oh because
from the Hebrew right and then a
chameleon one would look weird the vial
no it is look how cool that looks really
it would spin out right that was the
bike and that's our game of the year I
need to put some gas in yeah that's
right guess over the monster parts
whatever you want remember you want baby
anything it's like what's blank it's
like a partial problem because the
texture too and then you can even use
the best your like trash like the 87
type Doc Brown is thrown in like banana
peels into the DeLorean plantain peels
so everybody yeah they're really
eco-friendly in I guess the past slash
future of Zelda they're ancient
technology was
hi Linc that's my backyard the horse is
like all right
so okay so one thing you know we always
talk about it's running away from
figuring out things that we didn't know
we're possible in this game is there a
way to propel the bike faster that maybe
we don't know about well they like you
can make ramps with stasis and magnets
this and then maybe you want a metal box
behind it so the paper is pushes shaded
a few times can you try to probably
knock you off the bike then wouldn't get
on the bike really fast
yeah wipes out can you try that Rob you
tried that little ones later on sega
putting like something behind the bike
like on the ground stasis and then hit
it a shit-ton of time still the arrows
read then get on the bike
okay propel you sure let's try it have
you tried it nope oh I know the perfect
spot what Death Mountain no I just know
that there are some especially large
metal boxes in this area they don't have
the metal just needs to be able to get
stasis but metal boxes it's a good I'm
just Rangga stoke a of the boxes I like
how like confirming things again
spoilers like obviously those are divine
beasts but like basically your bike is a
divine beasts fort link no I never I
never saw the loading screen with it
it's pretty sweet like when you look at
that in that respect and I think of that
that's the lore that justifies a frickin
dirt bike is that like all right you got
walking giant chameleon 80 eighties
practically like a little hot like so so
if you got like the Vadra time ask would
it maybe keep your temperature down in
the halogens is it merely be rude ah it
would be would be the other one elephant
ruda would what's the chameleon lizard I
don't know whatever mauritania yeah
something like that you if you got the
door on ancient masks yeah I would
imagine this would be heat resistance in
this area Ruda would be swim I bet you
could swim faster with it
Gerudo would be heat again exhaustion
heat I'm spitballing here guys I could
just look it up but I'd rather find out
myself I know where this is
it's
it's uh it's over here so I'll do that
and then I could find out bingo was his
name-o Oh what am i doing what you can't
use the bike here no not in the Elven
region no you can't use it in the desert
either I think we'll go to like a bull
commie Campbell middleboxes
you know that one's work oh [ __ ] fire
keys wake your trunk you blue isn't just
wet and then immediately war back it's
super embarrassed
didn't swing in the right direction
that's like in Napoleon Dynamite like
tests the Tupperware and she's standing
just watching him they just annihilate
sit with this car
the hero of time we'll edit everyone
well I did that out and in the bar you
say that I'll fix it in post
shrink it in post though the wonders of
editing so what else do you have left to
do in this game um are you gonna are you
gonna keep playing it you know I was
thinking about that one starting over
now not starting over you know that's
something is I've been thinking about
like 100 percent yet hard core core ox
Oh as in not just Clorox but oh yeah
billing this [ __ ] hat dude yeah that's
the thing that uh become like become
like a National Geographic photographer
just like taking photos of everything
you can that sounds like a cool wind
plant series I've been doing that anyway
not in your whatever his name is voice
what was it David Attenborough yeah I
can't I can't do it
but Steve Irwin you can also just buy
those those things yeah that's more fun
to find them
no like the moon's right well I mean
different but yeah Lord that is boxman
everybody that's gonna break you your
duty both hey just like look at hiring
myself like Patrick Bateman except in
Zelda what a weird reference
there's your thumbnail right there oh
there's a metal box right there
you can imagine robbing real lineup
peeling up on a bike on the sidewalk
here's your thumbnail love these guys
don't think that you're their dad that's
their that's their backstory their way
of them daddy
lights out I didn't say that when it's
just you alone oh my god I would love to
be a fly on the wall that camera crowd
goes sick as if he's gonna take itself
he doesn't never took it oh my god get
like a ramp area right like up this hill
Oh make a ramp no no no I mean just like
don't shoot to the watercourse shooter
they did not do it looks like but by
destructive I hate
Alice that was you know that was tight
you know that was tight all right
calculated Mullins
style modeling very best Hey so
progressive sometimes in the water have
a drink
no oh you know I also figured out about
Magni sis usually there's a range to it
but if like a metal chest falls to the
bottom of a very deep lake they will
extend the range of it to allow you to
get the chest in that specific instance
I'd okay I believe but I showed Rob I
did an amiibo near the reservoir up at
the top near the fab mount when a roo
just fell off the cliff and down the
bottom lake and I saw it tiny at the
very bottom was like shaking it but then
they actually let you grab something
them far away if that specific thing
happens which is a good foresight Oh
dad's here
they didn't take off the set is taking
on it still there Alice as I fly back
dick alright well we've been told that
we've been told this we've been kicked
out of studio ended on something how
about a Lionel fight alright wrap off
something and like midair we'll call it
jump into the water
jump into the water that's not see the
thing about this bike that I love an
idea then is that horses are just
meaningless now all horses are obsolete
I mean this is your dead beside [ __ ]
cars new course is obsolete we still use
them I mean you feed this thing an apple
you gotta like throw it into its back at
least a horse will he's gonna want to is
alright alright let's kill one Guardian
this do game in real quick yeah you can
[Laughter]
you know what it's like GTA how long can
you do cinematic mode up Guardians fear
me so they've been a low-cost services
here also when Zelda showing up at
Skyrim this was why it was a monster
hunter before hmm
do you think there's anything that they
would put into Zelda oh because they'll
they did have so you know play turned by
its armor that you get yeah I wasn't too
fond to that I don't think it looks good
to begin with no but it also just does
seem very strange I'm not convinced
they're the production crew is steaming
right they're all quitting one by one
[Laughter]
problems a pro-gamer what are you doing
oh yeah I'm killing them yeah you sure
that wind cleaver you got planned dude
yeah I like those swords Danny more than
using them but they are nice for pushing
people off ledges yeah yeah that's a
sick thumb open the left oh I'm trying
my best
there's gonna pull the plug all right
finish it kill it sayonara sweet dreams
mother arrivederci Churchill there you
have it legend of zelda breath of the
wild the Rob's game of 2017 as decided
upon by the staff and it looks like a
lot of other outlets are agreeing with
us but that's beside the point
thank you so much for joining us for the
past couple of weeks and doing this
countdown should I do it more time no no
we just you just cut yeah Nier automata
we're mains via the finished hopefully
it's no sacrifice Wolfenstein to the new
Colossus horizon zero dawn divinity
original sin to Resident Evil 7 Super
Mario Odyssey persona 5 and legends all
the breath of the wild our top 10 games
of the year what an unreal year has been
for video game releases ever since
January kicked in with a resonable 7 and
gravity rush to going into rebels I
already said that I'm going to horizon
zero dawn and Zelda and the switch and
it was a fantastic year thank you so
much for sharing it with us and
especially wrapping up the year and
celebrating all these games with us it's
been really really fun and if you want
to go back and catch up on stuff it'll
all be on YouTube and GameSpot we'll see
you in the future at some point happy
holidays happy holidays take care